Yoga
three,
two,
one and we're live sugar Shawn and uh,
Tim Welch,
your friend that you
brought with you here today,
friend,
teammate,
coach from Montana,
Montana people.
It's good.
It's a good place.
Yeah,
it is.
But for what we do,
it's not the best place.
Yeah.
How much training can you get in Montana?
It's not,
not the best buy.
Like when I was there,
uh,
two years ago,
pheasant hunting with Anthony Bordain
and that guy is such a maniac.
He trains everywhere.
He goes every day and he found some club,
some local Jujitsu club
in Montana and Bozeman.
I was rolling with people.
Yeah.
Bozeman is probably one of
the better places to train.
But the one thing good about being
from Montana is when we're in Phoenix,
it's like a big process.
Getting a fight.
Sugar.
How many amateur fights you have?
Yeah,
I had 14 and the nae fights,
amateur MMA fights for kickboxing,
couple of boxing.
It was every weekend.
I,
if Montana,
Montana,
people just angry,
just want to fight the fight,
you can just sign up that week and fight.
So we get a ton of fights.
No Commission,
no commission.
Oh,
so it's a manly place that Montana.
Yeah,
it is.
It's quite manly.
I mean,
you guys have grizzly bears and shit.
Lots of grizzly bears,
wolves.
You know,
I was there,
uh,
two summers ago I went and just was like,
man,
I need to figure out a way
I spent more time here.
Wasn't Bozeman.
Oh yeah.
It's beautiful.
It's fucking stunning.
Yeah.
I definitely want to,
I enjoy being away from there right
now just because I grew up there.
Right.
Being in Phoenix is like,
I wouldn't,
I don't want to be anywhere else.
I love being in Phoenix.
The training there is insane.
Yeah.
Where we're at.
Phoenix is like the fucking Mecca man.
Like we get a train without
Gusto Mendez to Keanio every day.
Like he beat Hoffa Mendez.
He beat Cabrina.
He'd be Ryan Hall.
He's,
yeah.
He all these people and almost every mile
there's a really good gym like boxing,
Gym,
Jujitsu,
gym,
wrestling.
Jim Henry Cejudo has a club.
They're the MMA lab.
A junk crowds.
Like where we trained killers everywhere.
Yeah.
That's one of the best
spots in the world for sure.
Phoenix is a,
there's a few hotbeds for MMA.
Obviously la is a big one.
Miami a big one.
Phoenix is a fucking huge one too though.
Yeah.
The lab,
like it's,
it's a different type of gym
than a lot of other gyms.
I haven't seen many gyms
like stay together and I
think a big reason is because
of John Crouch.
He's like one of the best
facilitators out there.
He keeps everyone together.
If you don't show up to practice,
he'll text you and say,
Hey,
where are you at?
We got to get our priorities straight.
And he really holds everyone accountable
and I think that's why it makes it a
really good,
strong place.
Yeah.
He's one of my favorite coaches.
He's a,
he's just a super no nonsense guy.
Never blows his own horn,
not looking for any attention
and absolutely knows his shit.
Like when you hear him in the corner,
he knows his shit.
Yeah.
He's good to have there in the corner,
man.
He just,
uh,
be the leader kind of
everything and look over
everything.
And like he brought up Benson from
when he was a small like just starting.
So it's like we're lucky to be able
to learn after that and then be around
Benson in the room.
Like the,
he's got a work ethic like no other
like is no other joining the military.
I heard he was thinking about joining
the military I think is too old now.
Izzy.
Yeah,
I dunno,
I was too old five.
I heard about that too.
How old?
What is the limit?
I thought you could join the
military like up to like 36 or so.
Like once you get across a certain age
they have to make an exception for you.
You'd make that exception.
He's an animal.
Can Beast.
Yeah.
So we're lucky to be around him.
Like the work ethic he brings in the
rooms like no other like two and two
wrestling drilling.
I,
I feel like he'd break
any man on this planet.
She put the pace on you and it's,
it's pretty cool to learn from.
We're lucky to see it every day.
Yeah,
I mean that is one of
the most important quote.
Like there's a bunch of
important qualities in a fighter,
right?
Um,
being able to perform under pressure,
uh,
creativity.
Creativity's be,
I think that's one of the
places that you excel.
You really excel in creativity.
Like when I watched you fight like this,
kids fucking around out
there like you're having fun,
you're flowing.
You know,
when you were telling me today where
we're doing a little practicing,
you were saying that you were doing some
stuff in fights where you just thought
of it like,
why you're doing it.
It just felt like doing it.
Like there's people that can do that and
there's people that never do that right
now when they're in the fight,
they're tightened up and they're fucking
sticking to the script and maybe even
sticking to like the real basics,
you know,
like barely even speaking in sentences.
Right.
I don't even think a lot of people
think too much when they're in there.
It's easier to say.
Um,
I feel like when I'm in there,
I'm reacting.
I'm letting my,
letting them all my training takeover.
I'm not really thinking,
I'm just reacting to what they're doing.
And I think that it helps me do what I've
been doing is just reacting to certain
situations and
I just feel like I'm on
a step ahead of them.
Whoever I'm fighting,
I feel like I'm a step ahead of them.
He's really good at like,
the greater the chaos,
the calmer he becomes.
And that's the,
that's the truth.
The bigger,
the brighter the lights are,
the more he shining and completely calm.
And before that last fight against,
uh,
Andre,
we watched probably four of Connor's
fights right before we walked to the Reno
and sugar sitting there,
zoning in on those fights,
watching the way he walks out,
watching the way he's
good with his energy,
smart with his energy.
And uh,
you can really see it in the fight the
way he may make some and sugar can watch
someone,
someone do something and
he can do it right away.
It's a really cool talent.
Yeah.
Before the last couple of fights,
um,
before we go to the arena,
we just don't fight pass.
Watch Conor,
watch them walk out,
watch,
just watch him,
his body language,
Connors,
he's the man I love.
Gone or I've always loved Konner since,
since I remember watching
his first fight against,
what was the first,
like Max Holloway was at his first one.
UFC and the UFC.
Yeah.
I remember watching him and like,
that dude is going to be good.
I think that was his first fight.
He blew his ACL out in that fight.
Maybe that wasn't as first.
Maybe you think it was image?
No,
might've been
Marcus perimeter.
Right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I stopped.
He stopped image and then he blew his ACL.
Ah,
I want to say in the first
round against Holloway.
And then he started controlling them
on the ground and taking them down.
But that was a very
young Max Holloway too.
You know,
you're dealing with Holloway when,
I think he was like 20 or something.
He was young.
Yeah.
Super,
super.
Yet be,
fuck.
He's a beast.
He's cool.
He came down to the lab once.
I didn't,
we just kind of play around spar,
but he,
I'm,
I'm excited for that.
He's fighting Ortega next July 7th.
Yes.
Very,
uh,
very excited about that
hope and I get to get,
get in there.
I hope we can get them tickets.
That's going to be sweet.
Yeah,
dude,
I'll hook you up.
He's,
he's fascinating to me.
Uh,
Max because he's just this guy that like,
I knew he was really good and the knees
kept getting better and kept getting
better.
I'm like,
where's the ceiling on this guy?
And then you saw in the Aldo fight when
he beat all of the first time and then
the second time,
the second time you're like,
Jesus Christ like you,
you,
you really don't know how good a guy is.
Like you see them in a fight and go,
wow,
he's really good.
But then you don't see him
for a while and you're like,
is he better?
Has He slipped?
Is He,
is he training hard?
Like where is he at?
Like you don't know
until you see him again.
And then when I saw him in that
second Aldo fight him like,
Jesus,
he's so much better than he was before he,
he yelled at the end of the first round,
he looked over at us and he goes,
demands tired.
Like at the end of the first round,
I was like,
Jesus,
he was in and all though
was throwing bricks at him.
He was really throwing hard in that
first round to try to like establish some
distance at all.
He hit him with some shots,
but he,
I mean,
he had his heartbeat and rock them.
You know,
Max lost.
He's only lot,
well in the UFC,
he lost to Dennis Bermudez caught
somewhere early in his career.
He lost it.
Connor,
I think he only has two or
three losses in his career.
Three there.
Three losses.
Who are they to does it say and Dustin,
Dustin,
one 2012 oh,
okay,
good.
I love watching him fight
that fight against catchy.
I was,
I watched it live.
That was,
whew.
That was crazy.
He's a good,
I thought that was kind of going how,
how that was going to go.
He's going to outbox and he
was down some good combos.
Justin's leg kicks are a motherfucker,
but he takes too many shots.
He's just,
he's so intent on breaking people and
just keeping that pressure on you that,
I mean,
he's a fucking really good wrestler
and you never see any of it.
And his fights,
I think he posted something that he's
going to kind of switch up to say that.
Yeah,
I think he did.
But then he also said he might only
have five more fights left if he keeps
fights that way.
Yeah.
I mean he's just,
he's just fucking chaos.
It's just,
he's a Berserker,
but it's so fun to watch him.
It's like you don't
want to say anything to,
I'm pure entertainment.
No,
I mean,
fuck yeah,
he's the Eddie Alvarez fight
and the Dustin Poirier fight,
but they're so similar in a way that he
like almost gets the guy with his leg
kicks hall.
Most breaks him with those leg
kicks and then he got caught.
But it worked in the
Michael Johnson fight.
So it's like when you see it
in the Michael Johnson fight,
when you see like Johnson's
leg just starting to give out.
We watched Luis Watch file fight,
Luis Palomino in a
elephant with another fe.
It was a world series.
We watched that.
He's gnarly to watch live and he
kicks low from real close man.
Generates a lot of power.
Yeah.
He's like,
he literally tying up with you and
he's chopping down with low kicks.
He's got real loose hips with that,
you know,
he's able to really bend
his body and chopped down.
Nice,
tight high garden.
Wait,
let me come in.
He fucks people's legs up,
man.
He does Telford Shit.
It's crazy when you see guys like that,
like when they start to get beat,
you wonder if they're going to start,
use those losses as
informative or demoralizing.
Start to define themselves and
then start questioning themselves.
That's why with sugar in
training and in a fight,
even in training,
like he'll find the toughest guys to go
with and he won't go with those guys and
be like,
oh,
they're better than me.
And started to find himself.
We'll just use it as
informative and learn from it.
So it's like,
it's another good mentality.
He's has super positive,
good mentality and I think a lot of that
comes from eating good and having the
right rest.
And hydrating and eating good year round,
not just eating good during
a fight camps and blowing up.
And I think that's a lot
to do with it for sure.
Even the lifestyle,
just eating healthy,
like you said,
all year round,
not just getting healthy for six weeks
and then eating like shit after getting
injured.
Once I really started
learning about eating healthy,
a ton of small little injuries went away.
My back would hurt every morning cause
that what you're doing wrong before like
what were you eating?
Pop tarts,
sugar can just anything shitty.
I don't know.
Hot pockets,
top ramen and any,
all that stuff that was
just raised eating and all.
And then once I started realizing what
that stuff's doing to my body and how I
can feel it,
it changed.
It changed my whole mindset.
Like eating healthy was one of the biggest
things that improved my skills as a
fighter.
I feel like just as far
as my mental thoughts,
um,
my training sessions were so much better.
Will you just say in the
eat a lot of sardines?
No,
I said I had some sardines last night
and then I had some this morning.
That has a very good food.
They're not.
No,
they are.
Yeah,
dude,
we're so,
so lucky to have the internet and podcasts
and be able to learn from guys like
you,
Dr Andy Galpin,
like Aubrey,
Marcus,
Tim Ferris,
like Chris Fresh.
You ever listen to some of the
episodes with Chris Kresser,
fantastic information,
fantastic information on nutrition.
You know,
I mean there's so many guys like that.
Rob Wolf,
you know,
so many people that are like at the
cutting edge of performance and diet.
And Robb Wolf is interesting too because
he experiments himself on with his own
body quite a bit and it talks about an
online and he's getting really heavily
into Jujitsu right now.
And he does a lot.
I mean he's,
he's really interesting too because he
does a lot of ketogenic stuff but really
adds way more carbs on Jujitsu days.
And um,
I had Zack bitter on Zach one,
the uh,
what was the American record for 24 hours.
It's American record
for running 24 hours,
the most amount of miles in 24 hours.
Um,
he,
he's,
yeah,
he's a fucking beast.
And how many did he run and what does
he run like he ran 24 hours straight.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
A full day of running.
That's what we're trying
to find the balance though.
Like we're eating,
but you don't want to do that
on days that we're not training.
We're doing,
we're trying to do Kido,
so we're just keep the
inflammation down in her body.
But it's bitter guy that
I was just gonna say he,
he's a full Kido guy.
He's,
he mostly eats meat,
but on days when he has,
there it is,
he broke the u s 100 mile record.
That's what it was.
Seven minutes per mile for 12 hours.
That's,
that's the record.
That's right.
What a bad ass.
Oh,
he's a,
he's a fucking savage.
Mental thoughts I run in.
I wonder if he's just in the now just go,
it's gotta be in a trance.
But um,
he,
on days where he's running,
he way ramps up his carbs.
So like,
you know,
the average person is trying to keep
their carbs within like 50 grams or 75
grams to stay Kito you've got to
recognize that for extreme requirements,
like physical activity
ramped that shit up.
So Rob,
I'm just going to say that Rob Wolf is
really experimenting a lot with that.
It follow him on Instagram.
He's big up on that.
Yeah.
Like,
and we listened to a lot
of Ben Greenfield too,
so I was like,
fantastic.
And we're not training,
we're listening to you guys.
It's like we're treating
you guys like a college,
like your guys is our college.
And then we're going to Jujitsu,
learn from Makino going to
learn from John Crouch and like,
I dunno,
I feel like we're on a really good track,
especially for sugar.
Now how do you guys know each other?
How'd you guys meet?
Ooh,
good story.
I,
uh,
I was going to commentate and with belt
or at the time and going back to Montana
to commentate for some fights and a
shotgun for Beltour fighting for them.
Yeah.
And then I went to commentate some local
fights up there and I saw Sean and he
was says 18,
18 at the time.
And I saw him,
I was like,
damn,
I kid submitted a,
a wrestler and the first
round and I knew at his gym,
he doesn't rest it on.
My Kid's got some good talent.
So I invited him down after
I went up to him and I said,
hey dude,
you can stay on my couch for a little
bit and come check out the gym.
Kind of figured he wouldn't.
And I remember,
I remember the,
he told me that I was so jack,
cause I knew Tim,
I seen him on TV.
I didn't meet him personally,
but I've seen him on Bella
trees on the fight master show.
And uh,
after my fight I were at the sting bar,
like a local bar.
And he came up to me
and he offered me that.
I remember,
I think I called you the next day.
I'm like,
hey dude,
yeah,
I want to come down.
And we figured it out.
I think I came down a few weeks later,
months later,
I came,
not for 10 days,
and it was like one of the most,
the biggest ass wouldn't
have ever got in my life.
I remember when we were
driving from the airport,
he was talking,
he's like,
yeah,
I mean you were going to the top.
I'm like,
this kid has no idea what he's
about to get himself into.
Taking him to the pro practices,
all the people,
because as soon as you get on the team,
everyone fucking hammers on you.
The Hammer is on youth beat you,
they break you down mentally to
see if you're going to come back.
So I was,
I was there for a full week.
So Monday is striking it.
Tuesday at wrestling,
I literally did not know how to wrestle.
It didn't notice single leg was,
it,
didn't not know anything about wrestling.
Um,
I remember
a good group of people just want me bad.
I remember crying,
leaving practice,
running on high school to know nothing,
nothing.
And you,
what part of Montana?
You from a Helena.
The capital.
Um,
but yeah,
I never saw,
I boxed a little bit,
but I never,
never wrestled.
Didn't really grapple.
I remember I knew one arm,
I knew an armbar off my back is the only
thing I knew and that's what I caught
that wrestler and I,
I've got him in an arm bar.
I surprised I didn't even,
I was like,
Holy Shit,
I just did that.
But anyway,
came down,
got beat up bad for a week.
Um,
went back,
say,
went back to Montana,
um,
saved up $2,000,
packed my car,
drove down.
He was living with his
girlfriend at the time.
Um,
we stayed there for two weeks,
then we got an apartment.
Um,
and I,
I'd only known Tim a little bit,
but we got an apartment close to the lab
and I just literally went every single
day,
twice a day.
When he first showed up.
He like,
I was going to,
I smoked some weed in the
night and he was so taken back.
He's like,
Holy Shit.
He looked up to me,
couldn't believe that I was doing that.
Drove you smoked weed.
And my dad didn't find that the
detective in in Montana and I would just,
I was raised like weed,
not good,
not good.
Like that's what was going through mine.
I thought it was bad.
Like really bad about it.
Oh yeah.
I remember he came down
places that went backwards with wheat.
They had medical marijuana in
Montana and now they're removing it.
They're removing all the stores.
When I was there,
they were like,
they were having some sort of a
closeout sale cause they were,
they were getting shut down.
I don't know if that's
since been amended or fixed.
I don't know.
That's what sucks.
Died.
And when he,
when he moved in,
I was like,
okay,
this kid is fucking pissing me off.
He's not picking up his shit.
He'd not not doing his dishes.
He eats like mom did all
that for me and I'm like,
okay.
I either could get pissed
off and kick them out,
but then I realize I'm like,
he doesn't even know.
He doesn't even know.
So I'm going to work them.
I'm going to try to treat him like
my little brother and help him.
And he was willing to
like kind of follow along.
And then he started slowly
starting to eat better,
started eat spinach and his
back problem started to go away.
And um,
what kind of backpack on
my back would always hurt.
Always inflamed,
always.
I don't know what it was.
I just,
all time I remember getting
it looked at my lower,
lower back.
It was,
it was,
it was nothing.
It was literally from eating shitty food.
It's just all the inflammation from
all the shitty food I was eating.
And I didn't know that at the time.
I remember my mom took me in there,
like up beer back's fine,
but it hurts so bad always.
I started eating more anti inflammatories.
I started making shakes with spinach
and almond milk and blueberries and Chia
seeds.
I started eating healthier
and I'd slowly notice like,
oh,
I feel better.
I started.
So I started getting more
into eating healthier.
I remember just recently,
um,
I had a Vegan diet for six months and the
people on Instagram hate me now that I
don't eat vegan diet anymore.
You go off Vegan diet man.
That's like when you
become a Muslim apostate.
Seriously.
They want death to you.
Yeah.
Cause I've been posting pictures
like I posted a picture of,
I got this um,
grassfed beef jerky for
whole foods yesterday.
Got Probably 30,
40.
Why aren't you vegan anymore?
Or just meet like people though?
They,
they're mad at me for not
eating a Vegan diet anymore.
But I would say like,
I hate that Vegan diet for six months,
but I did,
I incorporated eggs and do
it cause I just couldn't,
I wasn't eating enough.
But I never,
I never felt bad.
I didn't feel worse.
I just didn't feel great.
Once I started eating good quality
meeting and I felt my energy levels,
I'd wake up on,
my energy levels were way higher.
I just felt more aggressive.
I felt more like manly.
Um,
so if he comes right now,
get getting angry in the content against,
in the contenders.
I know you lost me.
The contender series fight,
he weighed 138 pounds.
He was a Vegan at that time.
I walk sick,
lease dislike skinny.
There's more to that too
than than just the beginning.
I had a concussion,
a bad concussion.
Three weeks out from that fight
against Alfred and the tender series.
I remember waking up in
the middle night puking.
Um,
I couldn't train.
I remember I even woke up with a
little headache going into the fight.
Do you remember it was from,
um,
yeah,
well I was from sparring.
I hit hard,
boom.
And I remembered,
I'm like fuck.
But I knew it was the huge opportunity.
Um,
I like the matchup.
I knew I just had to go
out there and perform.
But yeah,
I was,
I weighed in at one 36 and I walked
into the cage at one 38 like I was,
it was,
and you can even look,
go by,
look,
go back and look at that video.
And it looked just unhealthy,
but it all works.
Yeah.
I just,
I was so skinny.
I was like 138 pounds right there.
Yeah,
I still dropped his ass.
Then
two weeks later we went to
to hang out with her buddy,
a Scott Holtzman in the UFC for a UFC
Fresno and a Dr Andy Galpin was with him
for the week and I knew sugar was with me.
He watched what the health and
that's what turned him Vegan.
So I made sure to ask doctor
handy in front of sugar.
I said,
how much would Sean benefit from eating
like elk or a grass fed meat twice a
week.
He's like fucking hugely,
hugely.
And then Sean right there
and made the decision,
I'm going to start making
some guys tell him if this,
if he's this smart and he's telling me
that some good quality meats going to
benefit me,
I would be stupid to not
take him up on that and,
and do that.
So,
and I don't regret it.
I feel so good eating meat again,
I feel way stronger.
It's hard when you see those documentary
and also you get a lot of positive
reinforcement from other vegans that
are very happy that you're Vegan.
Yeah,
they'd love that you
joined the team and look,
people want to be healthy
and for the most part,
eating vegetables is very healthy.
The problem is we,
there's a lot of nutrients that you're
gonna really have to search for if you're
just eating plants and it's,
the protein is not as bioavailable.
The amino acids are not as bioavailable.
It's very hard to get vitamin
B without supplementation.
There's a lot of shit that you're just
not going to get and they like bang for
your buck in terms of what the amount of
nutrients that you get in like a small
grass fed steak versus
a big plate of Broccoli.
It's just not the same and
they don't want to admit it.
And a lot of these feelings,
those,
I think those what the health guys,
I had the mom when they did Cowspiracy
I think they mean well but they are
fucking true believers and they,
they are not trying to put together a
documentary that states all the facts.
Objective Lee,
they're doing a vegan propaganda film
and on it debunked a shit load of the
things.
We had an actual nutritionists
analyze what they were saying,
go over the studies and they debunked a
shit load of what they put in that film.
That film is propaganda film and it gets
a lot of people thinking that this is
the way to go.
It's going to reverse heart
disease and help your body and,
but they get so many things wrong deep
into the meat does not cause diabetes.
Like this is nonsense like that when
they do these studies with people,
especially like um,
studies that they do on people that
show that people that eat meat more than
five times a week have a higher
incidence of heart disease and all these
different things.
They don't measure what else they eat.
These people that are eating meat all
the time or eating fries and shakes and
soda and you're not analyzing someone who
eats sauteed spinach and olive oil and
a piece of grass fed beef or bison
or elk or something like that.
No,
you're,
you're getting some assholes
eating Jack in the box.
Like,
yeah,
that stuff's terrible for you.
It's fucking sugar and refined
carbohydrates and nonsense and trans fats.
Oh,
that's those terrible for you.
If there's,
there's no studies that show that
eating clean like people have eaten for
thousands of years.
I mean,
literally if me caused cancer,
97% of the planet would
have cancer and that's,
that's the numbers that eat
meat on a regular basis.
It's like 95 plus percent.
Fuck.
And then those people
like that are vegans.
They're like,
oh,
I'm going to try a Vegan Diet.
And they're eating all these veggies,
getting these nutrients that they
didn't get before and they're like,
I feel fucking kid off that bullshit diet.
He stopped beating Jack the Box Star Jack
in the box in the middle of the night.
Sometimes I do go to,
as for comfort,
it's not Jack [inaudible],
he's just fast food,
shitty food,
processed food,
you know?
That's what the problem is.
It's like people,
like you're saying like ramen.
I like ramen every now and then.
Fuck,
it tastes good,
but it's not good for you.
I couldn't eat.
Yeah.
It's just like knowing what that,
what that what it does do your by
knowing that you are what you eat,
it's high.
Can't,
I can't cheat.
I can't do it.
If I have no,
that's not going to benefit my body.
I can't eat it.
It's hard.
What you eat like 100% and I so simple.
You know,
it's such a simple,
it's such a simple phrase,
but literally your body is
made out of what you eat,
not mouth.
Pleasure,
pleasure,
God damn man.
Ice Cream Sundae with hot fudge.
That's good.
But there's so many.
There's all these healthy you can,
you can replace all of
that with healthy stuff.
I haven't had any Quito ice cream,
but I've heard good things.
Some people said that there
are some Stevia sweetened
or Xylitol sweetened Quito
ice cream.
It doesn't fuck with your body.
Nice.
That new halo top man has that coconut
sweetened coconut milk and Stevia.
That's pretty tasty.
Yeah,
well there's,
there's stuff that you
can eat that is good.
And of course fruit,
you know,
eating healthy fruit.
I mean,
look man,
a nice,
delicious ripe peach is about
as fucking good as any bullshit.
Fucking fake dessert you're
going to get anywhere.
We don't appreciate it because we think
of it as being like a healthy choice.
So it doesn't,
you don't get that I'm being a
naughty boy reward that you get from,
you know,
having a banana split or something.
Fuck God.
It's just not worth it might asleep up.
Yup.
It fucks your blood sugar up.
And that's the thing.
It's crazy that most people don't know.
They're like,
God,
I just eat and I'm tired and
then I just get started again.
They just don't know about
those blood sugar fucking,
yeah.
The insulin spikes.
And I had a regular coke the other day,
like a couple weeks ago for
the first time in years.
How calm,
oh,
just whatever it was there.
So I haven't had a coke in forever.
Let me have a coke.
And I was,
it was,
I was like,
it was like drinking
syrup like this sugary,
it was like felt thick when it was,
when I was chugging it down,
it was,
I was like,
no,
no.
But I did feel like
shit after it was down.
I was like,
Ooh,
I feel terrible.
But how many people drink
those fucking things every day?
Every day.
42 at 34 ouncers or what
are the three towns?
Pop.
It's hard.
Yeah.
It's hard cause it's a who
you're surrounded with to like,
fuck dude.
If you're surrounded with everyone,
like,
oh come on pussy.
Just have a good time.
Enjoy your life.
You're like pocket.
Right.
And then you're like,
exactly.
That's,
that's not like who you like,
it's such a common thing.
You are who you surround
yourself with but people don't,
I dunno.
It's like I'm so lucky that when
I was surrounded myself with Tim,
like he introduced me to eating healthy.
I remember when I was 19 I
moved to the lab every day.
We have pro practice Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday,
Thursday,
Saturday,
every day I was going to the coffee shop
and reading mind gym books and meant
not like all these mental books
and we're doing it together.
We were reading constantly
improving each other,
wanting to get better,
want to do help each other improve.
And that's,
it was so important for me to,
you are who you surround yourself with
and I see people not surrounded with
themselves with the best people
they can be around and to trap.
Yeah,
it's a terrible trap.
But sometimes those people that are not
the best people are really fun to be
around the problem.
That's a distraction.
It's like what's keeping you back from
wanting to be the very like I want to be
the best Bantam weight in the world.
Like what's keeping you people back
from wanting to be the best of them and
still just distractions.
People who are fun to be around alcohol,
you know,
even women,
like certain foods,
like distractions of what's keeping you
back from wanting to be the best you.
So it's just our brains are crazy.
Our brains are not.
Yeah,
I mean just,
well you got to think about
just what you do for a living.
I mean just that alone is crazy,
right?
The desire to be a professional fighter,
to desire to fucking kick people in the
head and choke them and have them try to
do it to you.
And this is what excites you and that
this is what's driving you to go to the
gym to improve constantly at,
I mean,
that alone is crazy,
you know?
And then these other people that are
living their lives and drinking too much
and smoking too much and eating
shitty foods and you know,
they,
that's their path.
You know,
they're there but their path
is not compatible with your
path.
That's the big key.
I like how Kyle Kingsbury said like,
uh,
like there's going to be some point in
your life that Health Jermaine priority.
There's going to be some point when
you're old and you have a disease or it
could be now,
but I was lucky enough to like when I
was 20 and 21 learning these things,
I moved in with Robert Follis and got
to live with him for a while and I was
like,
damn,
this motherfucker's got
bookshelves of books,
super smart.
And I'm like,
why is he eating all that?
Why does it go to this trader Joe's place?
So I started going to
trader Joe's and I'm like,
Robert Falls would always say,
he's like,
how much do you train your mind?
We train Jujitsu,
train wrestling,
we train all of this.
How much do you just sit
there and train your mind?
And I was like,
fuck.
So I just started reading books and
started reading about eating healthy and
super lucky to learn
and be around that guy.
He was probably one of the biggest
influences in my life because I was raised
Jehovah's witness my whole life and he
was raised Jehovah's witness his whole
life and I carried a lot of fucking
guilt for not being in the like religion
slash,
cult.
And he's like,
dude,
you're not a good person
because of that religion.
He's like,
you're a good person cause
you're a fucking good person.
And then just started telling me
to read and do your own research.
Don't listen to these people,
do your own fucking research.
Learned a lot from that guy and that
they've got to pass it on to sugar.
He was a gem.
I really,
really loved that guy.
Such a great guy to be around.
I mean,
I didn't know him enough.
W you know,
really when he died,
it bummed me out so much.
It was like,
God damn,
I should've spent more time with that guy.
Isn't that crazy?
It was the only got to meet him.
I only met him like three or four times,
but every time I was
around him I was like,
it was cool because he taught
him so much and I get to learn.
I'd seen like that's where
he learned it all from it.
Like Robert's a smart dude.
Yeah.
That's good.
Bummer.
You know a guy like that would
want to end his own life.
Like how is that possible that
someone was so loved and respected and
appreciated?
It really just highlights,
you know,
the,
the real issues that people who have
mental illness and depression are going
through.
You know,
it's like it's not,
it's not obvious to people on the outside.
Yeah.
And I think I know what someone's,
you just never know how
someone's feeling or thing.
You know,
his brother committed suicide and I think
that's what made him start like maybe
getting into pills or alcohol and stuff.
But it was weird because he would always
be the one that the answer for you to
wear your problems.
You have the perfect answer,
super intelligent.
So it kind of freaked me out.
I'm like,
man,
I want to,
I want my life to be like that guy.
I want to be like him when I grow up.
When that happened,
I was like,
fuck man,
I couldn't believe it.
How did you get out of Jehovah's witness?
Uh,
my parents got divorced in eighth grade.
My mom moved to Canada,
was still a Jehovah's Witness and uh,
I lived with her for a while
and I just was super trapped,
couldn't hang out with anyone,
couldn't do any sports.
And I was like,
fuck,
I have to make a decision.
Go with my dad and get out of the cult.
And all the elders were like,
don't do that.
That's a mistake.
But I made decisions.
They have elders too,
just like the Mormons and I'm,
and I made the decision I'm going to
go move with my dad and moved back to
Montana.
And then my dad was super into UFC,
so I started wrestling
and boxing when I was 14.
And then on from there,
my,
uh,
one of my wife's,
well,
how do I put this without this person I
know was a heavily into Mormonism and uh,
they,
they had people come over the house
that were elders and the kid was 20,
and he was like,
this is elder Mike and Mike
the fuck it is elder Mike.
Well,
he talking about elder 20.
Dude,
I'm like up there and get some pussy
that it's so preposterous.
You fucker.
You know.
And they were,
um,
they were going to other
countries as missionaries,
getting these people and riding their
bike South America and you know,
going up to him and send,
Hey,
yeah,
come join the call.
I remember my dad was
watching the UFC when I was,
I had to have been 12 or 13 and I
thought it was the one I was like,
I remember telling my
mom that he was watching.
I told on him like that he's
watching two guys fight.
I thought it was the craziest thing ever.
I hated it.
I did not like confrontation like 1213
years old and I remember literally
telling on him my dad
that he watching the UFC.
It's funny looking back on that.
That's hilarious.
Yeah,
it was funny.
Remember who was fighting.
I don't.
I remember he,
I remember chuck and Tito and then Uriah,
Uriah Faber.
Those were the three guys.
Like I remembered
their names.
Yeah.
Can you believe they're
going to fight again?
Are they getting along again?
Chuck and Tito are supposed
to be fighting again.
Yeah.
When this year and next thing he knows
it's for Oscar de la Hoya is burgeoning
MMA promotion.
Tell him you're not going to watch,
so I will
pay you.
Fucking got me,
man.
You got me.
I mean,
I probably will have to watch.
Didn't pick that up.
I don't think Bella Tarr wants it.
I think Bella tours cautious.
You know,
I know Bella tour was talking to chuck,
but you know,
I mean Dana White said it best is a
reason I asked him to retire 10 years ago,
10 years ago.
I mean,
look man,
there's a number here.
It is.
Tito Ortiz is announces,
he's coming out of retirement for
Chuck Odell trilogy is that today,
May 11th.
So it's like,
oh,
okay.
Yeah,
it's happening man.
It's happening.
I wonder how their training
camp you're going to go,
but they're going to be hurting,
you know,
a lot of Mris.
Serious one,
two sessions a week.
Well,
Tito is in remarkably good shape.
Believe it or not,
cause he's had a significant
number of back injuries,
but other than the chocolate Dell fights,
he really didn't take a lot of headshots.
Yeah.
You know,
it didn't really take
a lot of head trauma.
Yeah.
Tito's a tough motherfucker,
man.
He's been,
he's been around a long ass time.
And when he fought chuck,
the gap in striking was just so large.
You know,
Tito was always,
uh,
a competent striker.
You know,
he was a strong guy and a great
wrestler in his ground and pound,
but some of the best,
I mean,
Tito was one of those guys never
bothered passing the guard.
He was like,
fuck you and fuck your guard.
Teen quest.
I'm going to get on top
of you and smash you.
And there was nobody catching Tito Ortiz
and triangles get the fuck Outta here
with that.
You were getting elbowed
and punched in the face.
He was phenomenal at that.
But his standup could not hang with chuck.
Chuck,
when you think of chuck stand
up like it was never like,
but it was beautiful and a lot of
ways because of the knock outs were
spectacular,
but it was,
there was,
it was not sneaky.
You know what I'm saying?
There was no artistry to it.
There was no faints or swell is no like
Tj Dillashaw style movement or Dominick
Cruz or it was just a tag viking.
Ah,
just smash people and skillful,
don't get me wrong.
It was a very,
I mean,
look,
he,
he fucked up a lot of really
good guys with solid technique,
but it was just so overtly aggressive.
Like his style was so aggressive that
that style just caught up with him.
I mean,
he's got,
he was in so many wars,
man.
I mean,
just so many fucking crazy wars.
It's weird the confidence,
like you see like,
it's so good.
I feel like when someone knocks people
out early on in their career and they're
like,
oh shit man,
I fucking touches guy.
He's gonna fall sugars,
knock someone out with
every limb on his body.
So it's like,
he knows he can touch this guy
with any limb and what they do,
what they fucking fall over.
And I think a lot of people
late in their career,
they'd never knocked him out.
They don't believe that at all.
And I feel like you can see that big time
and fight or a wrestler knocks him out
for the first time and then you're like,
oh,
addicted Johnny Hendricks style.
Right.
Well Hendrix for a while had
some magic power in his hands.
It was weird,
but it's weird is that it went away.
It didn't make any sense.
If you see like his fight with Martin
Kampmann or his fight with Fitch or a lot
of the guys he fought,
he would just fucking one touch these
guys and they would fly across the cage.
Like he had magic in his hands.
Luck Dude Hendricks for a while.
Man,
I don't know if he got injured,
if his shoulder got fucked up,
if he couldn't throw the way he used
to be able to throw whatever it was.
You saw the whatever it was,
whatever.
Got them,
whatever got them.
He motivation time,
just father time,
whatever it was.
But God damn it just went away and
then he became not a dangerous striker.
It's so weird.
Fucking weird.
And that's another thing like whether
it's Usada or whether they're using those
losses.
There's informative or demoralizing.
Well,
we all know everyone who has been around,
Jim's knows things that
have not been published.
We know people that have not been caught,
but we've seen them dip significantly
when they had to go off a cycle because
they're going to a place where they
were going to get tested regularly.
We've all seen it.
Yeah,
and it's,
these are stories that like you hesitate,
like should the general public understand
what the real risks are because these
fighters that go to,
would you say you go to someplace
like rise in and they're like,
hey,
go crazy.
We don't give a f.
You want to give a fuck
old school pride go crazy.
We don't give a fuck.
But then
when those guys come over and try to
compete in the UFC and the UFC is like,
okay,
fill out this paperwork.
It gets,
you know,
give us your whereabouts.
You've got to sign in everywhere you go.
And then they start showing up.
When someone like Holly Holmes
had been tested like 19 times,
they just show up.
Knock,
knock here.
Time to pee.
You know,
let's,
let's check your blood.
Let's see what's going on in your body.
I'll make sure you're not
doing anything stupid.
All right,
go back to sleep.
I mean you,
if you come from this place where
you're allowed to cheat basically,
and you're doing it all the time,
which we all know a lot of organizations,
I'll allow that to happen and then
you could try to come over to the UFC.
You're going to see depression,
you're going to see lethargic,
you're going to see people
that they're just there.
They're in a dour mood all the time.
They're always sad,
their body's broken down.
You see the,
they shrink.
You started seeing all this loose access,
skin,
their arms,
they're not defined anymore.
Fucking horrible,
but they want to fight and they
want to make the money and you know,
hey,
it's his 30 and 30 if I win,
you know what I mean?
Money.
Yeah.
Maybe I can go to Guatemala and hideout,
do deep ball for six weeks.
I did a lot of fighters too.
It's like what defines them?
Yeah.
It's fucking what defines him.
That's all they got.
That's all [inaudible].
They're known for their whole life.
Like,
oh,
he's the fighter.
When did you next night when your next
fight and then if you don't fight for a
couple months,
you've got people like I broke my jaw,
my last fight constantly people asking,
so when you fight,
hey,
you done fighting me.
He doesn't find,
it's like,
fuck.
How long ago was that in August.
The fucking first punch of
the fight broke it clean,
still went into the second round.
I was trying to finish him,
trying to put them away because I knew
if I win one more I'll get back in the
UFC.
So that was a tough one.
But uh,
it,
it forced me to meditate.
It forced me.
I would have my jaw wired fucking tight
shut for eight weeks and I couldn't talk
because my TMJ joint would flare up.
So I'd have like bad headaches.
So I'd had to sit in
my chair and I'm like,
okay,
I have to do this.
So I just read,
started meditating and I'm like,
dude,
you just suck liquid through
your teeth every day,
all day.
I remember when I hurt my foot,
I was like,
we were in the ambulance going to the
breath to us by going into the hospital.
And I remember thinking
this could be worse.
I could have my mouth
and hanging off of me.
And the thing is it happens man.
Er Guy,
there was no one in the year and they're
like you need to let the inflammation
go down.
So I had to go two days and drive
to another city with it hanging off.
But like I said,
I wouldn't trade it.
I wouldn't take it away cause I started
meditating and now sugar is meditating
and man,
we've gotten so much
fucking benefits from that.
It's crazy.
Even now we're built on it.
Yeah,
I do.
On the tank.
Oh yeah.
Meditating in the tanks in your house.
I have one right here.
Yeah.
So sweet.
That is so such a fucking benefit for me.
It's like when the world
gets weird and world,
my world is weird as fuck man.
You know,
I tried to explain it to people.
I'm like weird being me.
I bet.
You know.
And to be able to just
take some time and just,
it's just look at it
all through fresh eyes.
Like that's the place for
me at the end of that tank.
I like an hour,
but I do too.
If I have the time,
I like two hour session.
It would be,
yeah.
Got,
then you have it here
is what it's all about.
So I can just do it anytime I want.
Hell yeah.
Like I wake up at three
o'clock in the morning.
You just drive over here.
Sweet.
What's your morning routine like?
Or do you have a morning routine that
you like or do you just kind of cardio?
That's what I like to do.
Or fasted yoga.
That's my,
my most recent thing as I'm doing either
14 to 16 hours depending upon what my
day looks like.
Intermittent fasting.
And then,
uh,
I usually either like yoga or running in
the morning today was running and then
I'll do something in the afternoon.
Either martial arts related
or weightlifting related.
Do you,
uh,
do you drink coffee every morning?
Like when you,
right when you wake up or,
not always,
but I like it.
I like these things.
She's Nitros who's caveman?
Nitros a lot like regular coffee too,
but I drink water with
Himalayan salt in it too.
That's one of the first things.
Yeah.
I could put a little lemon in
there to the certain times.
Sometimes I'll throw a little cayenne
pepper and that mother fucker.
Wow.
Any apple cider ever
vinegar to that stuff?
Sometimes too.
I take a lot of probiotics,
a lot of,
I eat a lot of Kimchi.
I find like Kimchi and gave me is like
I've been on this kick for the past three
or four months where I just
eat Kimchi and elk like three,
four times a week.
I mean on stuff do it.
It's hard when you eat milk before bed
and you wake up hard as rob won the fuck
people up.
People don't know
the super athlete.
If you eat elk,
you're,
you're literally eat a super athlete.
You know it's bad ass like another reason,
not just a doctor Andy,
but listening to you.
You talk about it because it's
in your podcast all the time.
Talk about how how beneficial
eaten those kinds of meats are.
And I'm just like,
God,
I got to do it.
And I would just,
I feel,
I feel so much better doing it.
Well,
if you think about like how
healthy it is to eat salmon,
like a healthy wild salmon,
that is a,
an animal that's out there hustling,
you know,
Sam and making its way up river,
you eat one of those things.
It's just loaded with
nutrients and essential fats.
When you eat an elk man,
you're eating an animal that's getting
away from wolves and bears and fighting
to the death with swords
grown out of its head.
I mean,
literally it's a forest horse with
fucking spears grown out of its head and
they're just out there
hustling serious day.
You know,
living out in Montana in the winter,
in the middle of the fucking winter,
running from wolves and shit.
I mean,
that's their life.
You eat one of those things you eat.
It's like,
Oh fuck you get charged up.
It feels,
I've given it to people who've never
eaten it before and they're like,
Holy Shit.
And My,
yeah,
you feel different,
right?
You feel like even their DNA.
Do you ever do listen to Paul Chek?
Paul Chek,
he's the [inaudible] Guy,
right?
Isn't ain't no.
He's been on Aubrey's and stuff.
He's a no,
I'm thinking of Paul Vernac
thinking of different guy.
Yeah,
I've have listened to Paul Chek.
I listened to him on Arbery's punch.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
Fuck.
He's a wizard.
He was explaining how
a pasture raised eggs,
just regular eggs that were literally
eating the DNA of that chicken and it was
he,
I don't remember what exactly he said,
but it blew my mind.
I was like,
he's awesome.
He would.
That'd be,
that'd be good.
Podcasting on him.
That would be sweet.
I'd have him on for
sure would be so sweet.
Chickens.
They love to eat bugs and worms and
grass and they will love to roam around.
And if they are allowed to do that,
they get a dark like an orange yolk that
you just don't get from those God damn
grocery store,
eggs,
chickens,
those grocery store chickens are prisoners
getting little prisoner eggs eaten
that putting it into your body,
it's better than nothing.
But it's nothing like a farm
raised free range chicken,
egg.
And you could get those at farmer's
markets and stuff like that like,
but you could tell the
moment you crack them open.
I mean it's just orange,
like the sun,
you know,
take care of your chickens.
Yeah,
y'all have,
what's that?
Are they a pain?
It's not the easiest thing really.
You know?
Yeah.
You got to clean the shit and you got
to make sure they have enough food.
And for me,
I got a squirrel problem.
My wife wants to kill
the fuck at squirrels.
Me.
I'm like they're cute little fellas,
right?
But they steal all the food.
They're fat fucking squirrels cause they
keep figuring out a way to get into the
chicken coop and get all the chicken
food and they're just in there all the
time.
But now I might have to put them to
death because I found out they'd been
stealing eggs.
The squirrels have now figured
out that they can get eggs.
And so a squirrel was trying to roll an
egg out of the chicken coop through the
hole that he comes in.
We caught him doing that.
I didn't catch him.
Catch him.
How are you going to get a little fucker?
I Dunno.
I bet it feels good.
I've never,
I never hunted and uh,
but it feels good shooting and
then eating the meat you get.
It does.
I'm nervous though because I feel like
I'd feel so guilty shooting an animal.
You will.
I remember I shot up
there a little bit longer.
Look at him.
He's got an egg.
That's yours.
No,
it's not.
I'll pull that back.
Jamie.
This,
I had no idea that squirrel's did this.
I had to find out on my own yard.
These little faces.
Their egg Steelers,
Bro.
They,
how do they know?
How do they know?
They're so cute.
They fucking know at times
a little motherfucker.
You got the chickens.
Chickens don't know what
to do but it's bloody.
Yeah.
Squirrels or they're not
smart but they're determined.
I think I might have to run a
fucking Arrow through a few of them.
Yeah,
but I don't want to kill the squirrels.
That's the city.
Like I don't want them eating my eggs,
but I also don't want to kill
them so I don't know what to do.
I know it's like they have one last way
to block off their holes but they keep
opening new holes.
Fuck.
Cause what this guy did?
He made a protector boxers.
Oh,
I'm not sure we're doing just like my
brother and my brother says though,
man,
if you,
if you're hunting and you're,
you're a really good shot,
you're going to put that thing away
and it didn't even know it died.
It lived a great life.
I home,
it's done and you to meet like,
listen man,
that's the best case scenario.
Yeah.
Here's the thing though,
they don't live forever anyway,
and the way they die in the wild by
getting torn apart by wolves or coyotes or
mountain lions is way worse
than a bullet or an arrow.
You know?
I mean,
the life of an elk is a
quick life if you're like,
not that one,
but the one that one's probably
only like maybe five years old,
but the one outside,
the big one over by the mats,
that one's about nine years old.
That's about as old as you gut.
If you find like a 10 11 year old elk,
Holy Shit,
that guy's live forever and their teeth
are all worn down and I didn't know.
I didn't know that.
I had no idea.
Yeah,
they don't live very long.
You know,
it's a hustle and they're,
they're out there just fighting for
their life and trying to get by.
Most of the time they're just grazing,
but they'll look up and they'll see
a wolf or something and it's like,
fuck,
it's on,
man.
I have some friends that live in
Idaho and you know w I know who has a
considerable both population and they
went on this scouting trip and when they
were up in the hills they kept finding,
they found four dead really large bull
elk that were torn apart by wolves.
And over the course of
like a 10 mile hike,
they found four of them laying
there dead torn apart by wolves.
And they're like,
Holy Shit.
Like this is crazy.
So the wolves will eat part of it,
leave it there and it's
cold as shit where they are.
They don't have to worry
about the meat going bad.
So they'll kill it,
tear it apart,
and then they'll find
another one and they'll,
their instinct is to
go after the next one.
They don't,
they don't like just kill one
and say we've got enough food,
we'll eat this until we were full.
And then when we get hungry,
go hunt another one.
Yeah,
there's hunters.
They do what's called the,
what do they call it?
It's not like they don't
call it sport hunting.
There's a word for it when they
kill like they was in Wyoming.
What was that one crazy story in Wyoming,
they killed 19 elk and
didn't even eat them.
Yeah.
They don't read for fun.
No,
they don't do it for fun.
They can't help themselves.
It's like surplus,
surplus killing.
They just,
they know they can get away with it,
so they just do it and then they'll,
they'll cash them.
Yeah.
Look at this.
19 out they,
they,
they recovered all of
them and stacked them.
They're not little either,
bro.
These are the ones they brought
down from Canada to the wolves.
They brought them down to the 90s to
repopulate Yellowstone because we had
eradicated wolves from
most of the western states.
Do you see that animal they just found
in Montana and they don't even know what
it is?
Yeah,
it's a wolf hybrid.
I saw a wolf vibrated with what?
The dog?
Yeah.
Wolf probably fucked a
German shepherd or something.
They do.
Most of the time they kill them.
They'll kill dogs.
They eat dogs constantly
that he funded that one.
Yeah.
He's probably hungry or probably
horny rather not hungry and just said,
fuck off.
Fuck this dog.
And see what happens.
Yeah.
Or a dog.
Fuck him or fucked her rather.
It could've been that seriously.
I don't know.
But you saw it.
Did she?
That pictures of that thing.
To me it looks like
a wolf dog hybrid.
Like maybe if somebody had,
what does that does this crazy Russian
dog that looks like a werewolf.
It's this weird Russian dog that's like
fucking crazy hair all over the place.
And if a wolf fuck one of those,
it would probably look like this thing.
Yeah.
Did you find that thing?
What does it look like?
They're good pictures of
it so that picture sucks.
That's just the back of it.
And this is another picture of it.
It's head
wolf dog shooting in Montana
draws international intention.
Is it t?
To me it just looks like
a dog fucked a wolf.
It's just a big ass.
Hold the dog.
Fuck her though.
That is a big fucker.
He,
it's a big animal that
looks like 150 pound dog.
Jeez.
It'd be a little pickup too.
It could be like at Tacoma,
right?
It's hard to tell and let's crazy.
They look,
they're beautiful man.
I'm glad they're out there.
They're fascinating,
but they're rough on wildlife,
but that's,
that's their life.
Their life is out there killing and
the elks life is out there surviving.
And the way I feel about hunting is you
just dip your legs and your body into
that world with discipline and with,
uh,
an understanding of what you're doing.
And if you get lucky and
you get an opportunity,
you kill one of those
animals and bring it out.
And they'd like,
to me,
that is the cleanest,
best way to eat meat.
Yeah.
I just feel like there's no better way
in terms of like a Karma in terms of your
interaction with nature,
the understanding connection
that you have to your food.
There's just so,
and then health wise,
there's no Monsanto,
GMO,
no spraying.
I mean you're,
you're eating a pure
animal issue on Sunday.
Well,
Montana is the place,
man.
Go back home means shit.
It's one of the Montana is some of the
best elk hunting in the entire country.
I'd rather just eat my dad and brothers.
I'm more of a gathering.
That's good too,
man.
Hey man,
nothing wrong.
We've gathered a farming man.
Grow your own fucking vegetables.
You know that's the wrong cap.
That's the plan.
Eventually we're going to make a
compound and have our own animals.
Hey,
I'll give you guys some meat.
I got a whole couple
of freezers back there.
That would be so when you guys go back,
we're going to drive back then after.
Oh Shit.
Oh Hook.
Yup.
Thank you.
By the time you get home,
you'll have,
you won't even be frozen,
but it won't even be thought out yet.
How old were you when you
took your first rip of weed?
Weed?
I was third.
Well not really.
So I'd smoked when I was younger,
but it was only like occasionally at
like a party and always felt like a loser
for doing it.
You know,
like everybody else would
be getting high and,
but who toilet and,
but I was probably already drunk anyway,
you know,
like when I was 14 or 15
or something like that.
So maybe I smoked weed a handful of times,
less than a dozen times until I was 30.
And then Eddie Bravo got me
into it when I was 30 years old.
We were doing Jujitsu together and uh,
he was telling me how marijuana is helping
his Jujitsu and helping his music and
his creativity.
It was,
what the fuck is this
guy talking about,
Mike?
Dude,
marijuana just makes it stupid.
Like don't,
you know,
and he's like,
just try it.
And he,
we got high and uh,
I remember thinking like,
Oh,
this is what it is.
Like,
wow,
I did not know Sam.
Sam believe that feeling like you're like,
why it's this?
No,
it's just me and Eddie.
Oh,
sweet.
sorry.
I can't believe this.
We went and got something to eat.
We're talking.
Oh yeah,
we giggled like crazy.
Talked about all kinds of crazy shit.
And then I remember I started smoking
pot and getting on stage and got real.
It was her kitten.
Real creative with my,
my comedy and then smoking pot,
doing Jujitsu.
I was like,
I can't believe how was zoned
in and gets you with training,
smoking pot and hitting the bag to this
day is like one of my all time favorite
things.
I get paranoid.
I get freaked out.
I get weirded out,
I get,
I get freaked out,
but then I just fucking crap up my hands
put on the timer and just once that
sweat starts flowing and she's stuck
and it's almost like the paranoia
and the weirdness of it all.
You just fight it off by hitting that bag.
Boom,
boom.
You know,
and you hear the bell that says 30 seconds
and you're Florian and then you get
that one minute off to think about life
and the future and the fucking universe
and volcanoes and Guatemala
and Hawaii and Oh God,
the bell goes off again.
You've got another three rent,
few minutes and man,
it's one of my,
my Blake,
it's,
it's a psychedelic experience.
It's like a cleansing experience
hitting the bag when you're high.
I like sh I love shadowboxing.
When I'm high I'll take a rebel
at home and just sit there,
have a little mirror and I'll just
shadowbox don't even know how long.
I just can just shout a box for it.
Go.
Do you know what's weird?
Like you feel balanced when you're high.
You feel like,
like maybe like if you got an injury,
you feel it more,
you feel like we're laser off.
You know what I mean?
And like for me,
I,
I feel my transfer a power
better when I'm high.
Like,
like certain techniques I,
I really get the timing of
like when to turn the hip over.
I feel it more when I'm high.
I like,
I feel the connection
with all that tissue,
all of it working together.
I swear it helps you just stay
in the moment a little bit more.
Especially at night after you train
real hard and you're thinking about your
mind's going a hundred miles per hour.
Take one rep and you're,
yeah,
I like gravy.
Like hello.
Like everyone always ask if how much
I smoke when I smoke after surgery,
uh,
smoking all day.
The doctor said,
hey,
did they do to your foot?
So I tore the Liz Frank.
So I,
I think that fractionate
and tore the ligaments.
What is the Liz Frank,
um,
what is it?
Why is it called Liz franc was one poor
girl have a fucking horrible injury.
These ligaments right here.
I don't know frank.
And that was in that,
that was the Sukin tough fight.
Yeah.
Um,
I did,
I threw a kick and I landed and
I launched off my right foot,
throw a right hand and I felt
that snapped right there.
Cause
we,
we watched the replay.
Oh there it is right here.
So it lists frank joint complex.
Oh,
so that's where it tour.
I'm just glad there's someone
smart enough on this war,
on this earth to be able to fix my foot.
Do I think of my mouth?
I was like Bob Smart people in this world.
And so your,
what do you like 11 weeks out?
[inaudible] 11 weeks out,
10 11 weeks out and I'm,
I'm feeling about 85,
90%.
I go to the doctor and,
um,
a couple of weeks to kick
in the bag with that foot.
I was feeling good.
Yeah.
It's feeling like that was the first
time I kicked the bag and that felt good.
I was excited about that.
But it's awesome.
It's a,
it's great that they could fix shit man.
Seriously.
Thank God for smart people.
I know.
I was like,
I wouldn't be fucked right now,
but I guess this,
this,
this injury,
like a ton of people get it
and they just don't know.
They just,
they just let it kind of
heal and live with it.
But,
and what was it like,
like as it was healing?
Like what does it impede?
What's impede?
What does it stop you from doing?
What does it slow you down with?
What is,
what does it get in the way of things?
Walking,
just walking hurts so bad.
Um,
I,
I didn't do anything.
I remember the doctor said,
just stay off your foot.
I literally played fortnight.
I was playing,
like I was living a professional
gamer life for a month.
I was gaming eight hours a day.
I would wake up and I'd go and
game for eight hours a day,
three high.
The whole time I was smoking like,
cause I personally don't
like smoking all day.
I feel like it makes me unload and not,
it's not the weed,
it's me.
I feel I'm motivated,
I just don't really like it.
But when I was playing,
when I was gaming,
it was the best.
I just game and smoking all day.
But uh,
yeah,
I was,
I was I going with that,
the surgery of the fruit.
So let's talk about,
um,
let's talk about smoking weed.
Um,
I like weed as I can
nightly the celebration,
almost like I want to get
shit done during the day.
I wake up,
do my morning to go to the gym,
come home,
do what I do,
eat lunch,
play for,
and I go to the gym,
come home.
And that's when I'm like,
okay,
I earned because marijuana is so easy.
And I go there.
I know there's like,
you have a huge following of,
of,
um,
the people who smoke
weed and it's so easy to,
for marijuana to take over your life and,
and be in charge of you.
Um,
and I felt that when I
was gaming and smoking,
I just want,
I like want to do,
I'm like,
ah,
I don't know,
whatever.
Take a rip,
take her up,
take her up.
Um,
and it takes over your life.
And I feel like it's,
it,
it's such a powerful drug.
Um,
and I don't like the word drug.
It's such a powerful,
it is a drug though.
Um,
mass,
a lot of people probably masks
a lot of people's feelings.
How they truly feel.
It's so easy to get high all
day instead of deal with them.
Certain emotion.
Yeah.
Um,
so I just feel like,
I feel like people are
abusing it way too much now.
Some people certainly are.
Some people are,
and I think that's the case
with everything though,
right?
Is it is.
Um,
so this foot thing,
what did,
how did they fix it?
What did it,
what does the surgery,
uh,
some pins in to hold the
ligaments together or there
was two options that I was
going to get a plate in my foot and
then six later they were gonna I
was gonna get surgery
again to take it out,
lay it out.
And I was like,
that does not sound,
keep that played in new shit.
Well,
I land a lot of my,
a lot of my kicks,
you know,
you land with your
Special Ed with your Shin,
by land.
A lot of,
with my foot.
It's like a slap.
She'll look at Thompson.
Yeah,
he throws a lot of instep kicks.
I mean,
that was the karate way
for the longest time.
I literally remember I knock someone
out in Seattle with my foot and the dude
was out for like 10 minutes.
It was,
I remember that.
Yeah,
that was gnarly.
It was literally my foot
slapping his jaw and I was like,
Holy Shit.
That's most certainly can knock
people out with your foot.
I mean,
that's Phil Davis and Belterra
just knock that guy out.
That was his foot,
wasn't it?
Didn't this wetland cats weird.
You don't see it coming.
Yeah.
So the shots you don't see coming.
Yeah,
you're right.
Especially when they
come over the shoulder,
you know those,
those round kicks or come over
the shoulder from the outside.
Even Thomson [inaudible] through that.
That was the last prayer,
one of my favorite knockouts and he
came over like I literally looked at,
came over question why I was so sweet.
It's almost a question mark.
Yeah.
Almost like that one.
But you know the question mark one
comes straight up the middle ground.
I threw the question mark kick
landed and then that's when I did it.
That's what I remember.
Oh yeah.
I wanted to bring this up too.
I remember,
um,
you had,
you were,
I don't remember what podcasts with,
but you're talking about,
you were looking at my
Instagram and you saw the,
I did a kick to a guard pass.
I was in front of him,
did a three 60 yard pass and I remember
you saying he could do that in a fight
if he practiced it a lot.
And I've been practicing that,
so I've been doing that for a couple
of years now and I did it in that Andre
fight I was,
he was up against the cage and I three
60 past into side control and I wanted to
bring that up and tell you that.
But it was,
it works spinning.
The people don't know
what to do when you spin.
I spun it,
he covered,
you'd cover it up.
I'm past,
I'm already inside control now.
This is a moment they have to think
and when I'm a striking as well,
usually when I spend a backup and cover
up like I'm going to go to your body
when your body and I'm
gonna go to your head,
you can get away with a lot of stuff.
Other people can't you
so fucking athletic.
I feel like you could be a pro
and a bunch of different sports,
like his timing and his eyes.
Like what did the doctor say?
You have some of the best eyes.
Yeah,
I remember going to the eye doctor a
few different ones and they're like,
oh my God,
your eyes are,
there are some of the best
I've ever seen in my life.
Like they were taken back.
I Dunno.
I Dunno if that transfers over
to fighting and my distance,
you know how I see things coming or you
found your range such at a young age to
not like a wrestler likes
concept penetration.
Penetration penetrates
to start as a striker.
So he's got his range down so good in
his eyes and his timing and his reaction
time is so fucking fast.
So like everyone sees
him and they're like,
oh,
that's,
that's beatable.
But when with him in front of you,
it's way fucking picture length,
man for your weight class,
for band and what you're so fucking long.
And I told you when I saw you,
I thought for a second that you might've
been the son of Michael O'malley.
There's a guy named Michael O'malley who
was my original taekwondo instructor,
was a four time national champion.
Like literally one of the best taekwondo
fighters in the world in his play is
tall.
Yeah,
he's very tall and he fought
one 47 little skinny man.
It's like six three they
cut weight and taekwondo.
Yes.
Yeah,
but terribly nobody,
nobody knows what they're doing.
They cut weight and fight the same day.
But he was a,
he was a beast.
He was my original taekwondo instructor.
He was Jay Hahn,
Kim's prize student.
He was his number one student town.
And when I started,
Michael had stopped fighting.
He was just teaching and now
he runs a school in a Peabody.
But he basically taught me
almost everything that I know.
And Mr. Kim,
Mr. Kim took over as
well when he came back.
But when I first started training
there for the first year or so,
Mr. Kim was in Korea and I learned
everything from Mr O'malley.
Fucking long limbs.
Just that he was younger too,
so fast,
so fast.
He was so fast.
He would do demonstrations on people,
you know,
like demonstrations of the house,
set things up and you would see
him do things and it was just,
it was confusing.
You'd be like fuck.
Imagine if that guy was trying to kick
me like yeah cause you'd be fucked
because he was so good at setting
things up and footwork and movement.
And so when I saw you I was like,
Holy Shit,
this kid looks like Michael O'malley.
He's like,
I thought you were his son.
That's funny.
Like I really did.
I was like Holy Shit,
his son is fine cause I haven't
talked to Michael in a long time.
I really did think that you were a son.
That would have been nuts.
That would have been,
yeah.
I was like wow,
when I see this kid I've got to ask him.
Nope,
nope,
nope.
Maybe my dad,
who knows.
Maybe someone was on trial on journey.
You know what I'm saying?
I never know.
This one's crazy.
Massachusetts,
Massachusetts.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Um,
so when you first got together,
when you for when you
two first got together,
you were 18?
Yeah.
When he first,
when he was commentating the fight.
Yeah,
I was 18.
I'm going it down.
How old are you now?
23,
23 and so you guys have been hanging out
together and train together the entire
time?
Yeah,
we've been best friends the entire time.
So it's like in sugar really like looks
up to me and trust is my opinion and the
listens to me and that
makes me have to up my game.
You know,
I have constantly have to research cause
I know he trusts me and I know he looks
up to me so I have to make sure
everything's really top notch.
It's,
it's,
it's nice now that I'm in a
position to where I can pee.
He's,
he's my coach.
Like he's my main coach.
I can,
I'm paying him to be my coach.
He's focusing on me,
my diet,
um,
watching videos he sent like on Instagram
you'll send me videos of like we're,
I'm digital is my favorite
sport in the Geek.
That's probably what I've trained the
most in like since since my surgery just
pretty much what I've been
doing is just drilling in the G.
Um,
he teaches at a Jen soul fighters
and I go there and drill Monday,
Wednesday,
Friday.
Um,
but he's constantly sending
me videos of nutrition,
Jujitsu,
sleeping,
just any,
anything,
any knowledge he's sending me.
So it's,
he's such a huge benefit,
like a huge benefit to me to
becoming what I want to be in.
It's so awesome.
Like we're doing this
together so it's cool.
I remember being 19 and their apartment,
like this is what I wanted.
Everything like training and to
have to have him here with me.
Even just being here,
it's just so awesome to travel everywhere.
Everywhere I go he's,
we're going places,
we're traveling and we're training
everywhere we go or train.
It's awesome.
So how satisfying is it for you to see
him in a position like the Andre fight
where like I thought you made a big leap
in between that fight and who is your
around around.
That's right.
Which was a very good fight too,
but I was like,
damn,
this kid's getting better.
I'll be like,
you made a leap.
You are doing a lot of like weird,
unpredictable shit in
the [inaudible] fight.
You were moving around
a lot and I was like,
you will have real confident and like
you were just constantly moving forward.
How,
how,
how much is it?
Like how good does it feel
to watch someone improve?
Like that
dude,
it feels just as good as as if it
was me doing it sometimes more,
right?
Like sometimes like sometimes more.
That's how I'm like,
man,
yeah,
it feels fucking good.
But every after every fight I'm like,
dude,
let's treat it like we lost.
Lost that fight.
Always said that.
He said,
I go out cause I keep,
I'm tenant and all right now and every,
every fight I've won,
he said,
let's pretend you lost.
And I've improved so much in between
fights because I live this lifestyle that
I,
and I don't,
I don't really party too much when I do.
I like the party though,
but I don't really party too much.
Um,
my life,
my life is MMA.
It's like my morning is training my
afternoons training and he's constantly
saying,
after a fight,
let's pretend we lost.
Let's,
let's improve.
And I've been prn from that.
Alfred fight to that Andre fight.
That was less than a year.
I feel like I improved the most.
I was just constantly learning.
It's the sports fucking awesome man.
It was fucking awesome sport.
It's so awesome.
It's fucking crazy sport too though,
right?
It's so nice too.
Cause like,
ah fuck,
we're getting bored of
Jujitsu a little bit.
Let's go wrestle for a while or let's go
box for awhile and we can always bounce
back and forth.
It's pretty cool.
Riff fuck around with any weird
stuff like wing Chung or you know,
no.
Or anything.
Mushrooms the weirdest.
Yeah.
Mushrooms,
mushrooms are gonna change the world.
Yeah,
I think so too.
I met,
yeah.
That's where we're kind of like
dealing with like with sugar.
Like cause we're really starting to
figure out like what ego is and like,
oh so really,
really shit,
you know?
Accurate.
Totally.
Sure.
I've been learning,
I've been listening to a lot of podcasts
about ego and Aubrey Marcus and with
Aubrey Marcus and just a
bunch of different people
and it's scary learning about
your ego and like who you
really are and who you ego is.
And we're understanding the two different
people like fighting in this whole
life,
this whole like any like
Instagram's basically your ego.
That's who your ego is.
I feel like for me,
um,
Instagram.
Yeah.
I feel like social media
for your character,
like you push out what you want people
to think of you like that kind of thing.
Everyone does.
Like you post what you want people like
that's what people are gonna think of
you as whatever you post.
Right?
It's like,
and then like realizing because
like I was broke last year,
this time I was probably broke and now
I have a good amount of money and it's,
I'm realizing money
doesn't make you happy.
Materialistic things don't make you happy.
And I know everyone says that.
Um,
who was it?
What's Jim Carey's quote like,
I wish everyone could be rich,
wants to realize that they don't want
to rich and famous and famous to realize
it doesn't make you happy because
I have that a lot of people,
like my little brother,
I was telling him trying to like get him,
I want to pay him to help
run my youtube panel.
I'm like,
you can make $60,000 a year,
blah,
blah.
He's like,
oh,
that's not a lot and that's not enough.
I'm like,
dude,
you could literally not
have to work and be like,
help me with my youtube do,
but I'm trying to get
millionaires and it's just like,
that's not what makes you happy.
And I'm really,
I'm finding that out.
Like at a young Adam's like I understand
like my ego is motivated by money.
I love money and I love just this whole
fight game is just all about just,
I feel like I'm learning so much.
It's hard to,
hard to explain my brain and I'm still
trying to figure out all of this.
Everything I'm learning,
I'm listening to so
many podcasts everyday,
reading so many books every day and I,
I can't really explain what my brain
try try to explain what you were,
your original thoughts.
So like you feel like what you're putting
out on social media is the ego and
what you really are
like who you really are,
is something different.
Well,
yeah,
I think just humans in general,
we're all at the core.
We're all just want love and compassion.
Um,
and so you want that from fighting fight.
Like what makes me truly happy is training
digit to you're training in general,
eating healthy and being around people.
I love being around my dogs.
I'm watering my flowers.
Like that's what makes me happy.
That's what makes,
um,
what kind of satisfaction do
you get from fighting to show?
I love work.
I love performing.
Ever since I was a little kid,
I've always tried to perform in
front of whoever was around my,
if we had to get together a fan,
I get it.
I would always be in a loud,
obnoxious trying to
perform and do something.
I love performing like that.
Performing in front of huge crowds.
Like he was saying,
the bigger the crowd,
the more people watching them,
the better.
I feel like I perform.
Um,
yeah.
When you start learning about
that stuff and take mushrooms,
it really opens your brain.
Other different pathways and changes.
How you looking at this?
I think mushrooms are one of my
favorite things I've ever done.
I've done mushrooms pray
five times and it's,
it's,
we're right,
right after that,
right after a mushroom trip,
you feel you're so much more,
you realize everyone's going through shit.
Like everyone is going through some and
make you want to be nicer to people and
they just want to be kinder.
And then I get four or five months later
you start getting a deer and wild ways
and you're like,
oh I need to do mushrooms again.
Need a reset.
Have you done DMT?
I have not.
I'm actually kind of scared to
do DMT cause I know like that,
that's what I talk about my ego.
Like,
like even mushrooms,
they attack your ego almost Kinda,
you know what I mean?
And we need that.
And I need that ego to keep,
I dunno.
It's,
it's,
you need your ego right now.
So what
you're saying,
yeah,
we got a new Connor's ego is huge.
Con,
you need to have a big ego.
You need to have an ego
just to do anything.
We are.
Um,
but is it the ego or do you need to
have the desire to achieve excellence?
It.
Is that always the ego?
Can you do that without the self?
Can you do that just as a task,
as a goal and be completely committed
and single minded in your approach to try
to achieve excellence?
Can you do that without the ego?
Can you do it as a project?
Can you do it as a task?
I think so.
I think you can too.
I don't care if you build this character
that I want to build this person,
this persona,
but why do you want to build a persona?
Cause you see Conor do it.
No,
it's,
it's fun,
right?
This,
it's the whole fight game is like that.
It's just fun,
right?
Like I don't,
plus,
you know,
if we build a persona,
the bigger checks are going to cough,
right?
Yeah.
Like I'm not trying to not be me.
Like everything I do is me.
Like I just,
I don't know.
I enjoy trying to find a happy medium,
like a happy medium.
I'm going to come on this podcast
later in life and I'll explain why.
I'm just learning so much right now.
None of us feel like it's overwhelming
or Smith,
dude,
when I was your age,
I was a fucking idiot.
You know,
you're way ahead of the game.
It's just a part of life.
It's he is,
you know,
five years from now you've been in like
God back then I didn't know shit and
then five years later you'd be like,
ah,
back then I didn't know shit.
The more you learn,
the more you realize you don't know.
And then we get mad at her
parents and stuff like,
come on,
please listen to me.
Eat healthy.
Like read books.
I'm like,
her parents didn't grow
up with the Internet.
Like we're so lucky to
be learned from you guys.
It's just impossible to
change people's ways.
They have to want to change.
They have to be motivated.
They have to.
It's,
it's so hard to change people.
It's like if you've ever had a friend
that's been into drugs and it's been all
fucked up and you can't get
them to quit or an alcoholic,
it is almost impossible to
talk someone into changing.
They have to have some
motivation that's internal.
Yeah.
And that's the same
thing with eating good.
The best example you could set is by
living your life in a healthy way.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
That's one of the best
things about the internet.
You get to see all these people that are
doing things in a healthy way and doing
things that are exciting and inspirational
and then it makes you want to do
stuff.
Yeah,
that's good.
And wakes,
makes you want to take care of your
body and makes you really want to
concentrate on your mind and meditating
and just really get everything in order.
Yeah,
meditation.
So awesome.
It's really helping me every morning I
meditate for 10 minutes and I feel like
it's helping me throughout the day
understand why certain thoughts are coming
up,
whether it's from my childhood
traumas or just anything,
just certain patterns,
my arm,
cultural conditions,
thought patterns,
cultural conditioning.
Just meditating is helped me almost kind
of slow my brain down and redirect my
thoughts if I get angry or something or
if something covens understanding of why
I'm getting angry and I think I,
and I'm so,
cause I've been meditating.
I did it for the Terry on verified did
for the honoree fight and I would do it
randomly or in camp.
I wouldn't do it all.
And then now I'm doing it.
I want it to be a part
of my life every morning.
I've been doing it for
the last month alone.
Do you do for 10 minutes?
10 minutes every morning.
And now how do you do it?
Oh,
I,
I've been listening to Sam Harris,
um,
guided meditation on,
there's an app called headspace that has
a bunch of packages that whether it's
stress,
anxiety,
sleep,
um,
positive thinking.
Ah,
I just,
I just do the guided meditations.
I have all this little meditation room.
I go down there,
I first thing in the morning,
I get up,
I put the lemon in the sea salt,
I hydrate,
I go into my meditation room,
push play,
sit there 10 minutes,
meditate.
Then I go outside water,
my flowers in the morning routines.
My favorite thing I need to,
I wish everyone would have a morning
routine cause it's really like
it,
I don't know,
set you up for a good day.
It does.
And just don't have,
I don't remember the last time I had a
bad day and just morning routine sets me
up for a good day.
I love it.
Yeah,
I agree.
And routine John Danaher want wrote
some really fascinating piece on his
Instagram about routine,
about how important it is
if you're a great athlete.
He said,
you find me a great athlete,
I'll find you someone who's
life is governed by routine
and that this is the way
to check progress and this is the way to
constantly be moving towards your goal.
And a,
I remember reading that
and I said to myself,
this is something that I've
always known but never vote.
Verbalize.
I've never said it.
Yeah.
But it's something that
I've always known like yeah,
like everybody who's really good.
I remember I were at a sports illustrated
article a long time ago about who's
that fucking track and field guy who
won the Olympics a bunch of times.
His name was something Moses,
I forget his name,
see you so you could find this guy's name.
It was something,
but he was like an elite
track and field guy.
And uh,
what's that?
Edwin Moses.
He was a beast and just super,
super disciplined and I remember
he had like this routine,
we had his notebook and he would lay his
notebook out and write down all of his
different routes and he had this like
Matt that he would lay down and he would
do his stretching routines
and all this stuff.
And I remember thinking like,
Oh this guy,
this is his thing.
He does this all the time.
He just gets there.
He locks in and he does this.
And this was many,
many years ago.
I might have even still been
fighting when this was going on.
So I remember thinking about it going,
okay,
like this kind of,
this is like what elite
performers do when they,
when they,
when they're right at the
Olympics track and field,
it's so fucking boring.
You're doing the same
shit you just running.
Like you have to have a mind that to me,
that steel to be able to do that same
stupid shit every day to try to get an
extra 10th of a second here.
All right,
an eighth of a second there.
Fuck all that.
Right.
But I remember thinking like it was too,
it was at the same time horrifying to me
that someone would ever want to do the
same stupid shit and over again
until they won a gold medal.
But at the same time,
massively impressive that this
guy had this kind of iron will.
There it is every time Edwin Moses places
feed on the blocks from 1977 and 1987
he wants Moses,
arguably the best hurdler
ever won 122 races,
including a 107 consecutive finals
and set world records in the 400 meter
hurdles four times
within that 10 year span.
His journey to the untouchable,
to this untouchable level was marked by
personal innovation and determination,
proving that elite coaching and state of
the art facilities are not required for
supreme athletic success.
And there was um,
uh,
believe it was sports illustrated
that had an article about this guy.
And I remember just seeing him how
motivated I was seeing him stretching and
working out and going over his routine.
And I was thinking to myself like,
oh think about it.
Every time I worked out that
like what would Moses to how it,
yeah,
how would Moses I got,
I got,
I got to start writing shit down.
I've got to start really thinking about
everything I do and I got to start
putting it together on a
daily basis like he does.
That's what Robert Falls,
his favorite formula you'd always say
is consistency over time equals results
favorite.
And I got it tattooed on there.
And it's funny cause like once you get
good at one thing you realize like fuck,
I could get good at anything.
And I know what it takes is fucking
consistency to Miyamoto Musashi.
He wrote that in the book of five rings.
Once you understand the way broadly,
you will see it in all things.
Sweet.
Yeah.
And that's a dude who fought
people without fucking sword.
Oh God.
That's this guy at dance.
That's him.
That's Musashi.
Yeah.
I read that book when I was like 15 or
16 or something like that and he wrote it
in the 16 hundreds met Hailey.
Yeah.
Maybe it was the 14 hundreds I think
it was the 14 hundreds now that I think
about it.
Ah,
yeah.
Yeah.
He killed six.
That's what the six number six was.
He killed 60 people in
one on one sword fights,
killed,
killed.
Who that in your mind set
going into one of them?
Yeah.
Well he was a master at that.
Well,
his thing was so fascinating and I always
recommend the book of five rings for
fighters because one of
the things that it's,
it's so crazy about it is his thing
was balanced is that you should be an
artist,
you should be a poet.
You should be like,
you should understand how to
write calligraphy like that.
All these things are connected.
You have to be in complete
control of your mind.
control of your emotions.
You have to have complete control of
artistic expression and that this was like
the way to be a balance sword fighter.
Like his whole thing was that you can't
have any bullshit in your game like as a
human being.
You can't have any bullshit because when
you're dealing with one on one steel,
fucking swords whizzing through
the air by trained murderers.
I mean,
he was the best at it and one of the
reasons why he was the best at it was this
strict adherence to this Samurai
way that he was not just a warrior,
that to be a great warrior,
you also had to be great and all of
these other things you had to have,
you had to have a balanced perspective.
You couldn't be a meathead,
right?
You couldn't bite down your mouthpiece
and let the chips fall where they may.
That shit doesn't work
with sword fighting son.
That's bullshit.
Like it just like you said about GSP,
like he's almost too smart.
You're like,
fuck,
he sows.
He's too smart.
And sometimes in fighting,
just like the dumb meatheads
go to a certain level,
but just like he said,
when you're real smart,
you can go to a whole new level.
Yeah.
There's,
there's a benefit to being a
meathead up to a certain point.
Yeah.
Especially if you can take a punch
because leaving the was a savage.
There's a perfect example
when he met Anderson Silva,
Anderson was like not today son,
not today.
Welcome to the next level.
Give me several levels.
You know that was brilliant.
Matchmaking by the way,
by Joel silver when they introduced
Anderson and I was a giant Anderson fan
before he fuck cause I was watching him
in pride where he was fighting well but
then I knew he,
I knew he was better than that.
He was going through a lot of bullshit
and that's when he was with Moyie Thai
Dream Team and I think he had already
left shoot to box at one point in time.
But then he went over
and fought in cage rage.
He fought in England and when he
fought in England I was like Holy Shit.
When you got to see when
he fought George Rivera,
when he fought Lee Marie,
you got to see how God damn good Anderson
really was when he was in his prime.
So when he came into the UFC,
he was already in his thirties you know,
and his first fight with leap,
and I want to say it was like
32 33 something like that.
Yeah.
And it's oily and he let Chris Liebing
on fire and I remember watching it and
then I was saying this,
I'm like,
this is the perfect opponent for
Anderson Cause Lehman's an animal.
He's a fucking warrior,
is going to bite down as mouthpiece and
come swinging and Anderson is going to
be 15 steps ahead of him dissecting
him and different angles and degrees.
And as he comes forward he's just catching
them bank bank stepping over here,
pop.
Wow.
And then it was over.
It was like real quick.
And that was the world's
introduction to Anderson Silva.
Fucking crazy.
Crazy mind.
If I take a whiz boys,
yeah,
please go ahead.
Yeah,
Dude Anderson in his prime memes,
Som thin special,
he was,
he had achieved that state.
You know,
there's this elusive state of total flow
and he had achieved that against some
of the best fighters in the world.
You know when you see him when he was
at his very best and I just feel very
fortunate to have been there
to watch some of those fights.
I think fader in pride was probably,
it's like him and Anderson.
Those are the two all
time greats of that era.
Right.
And then mighty mouse who's
the all time great of this era.
But what,
what was so phenomenal about Anderson was
that you would just watch him hit that
flow state.
You know,
he would,
he would size guys up to,
you would see him move around.
He would start moving around
who test you a little bit move.
Yeah,
we give you a minute or
two and you'd be like,
man,
I feel pretty good.
I'm doing pretty good in this fight.
And then all of a sudden he
started opening it up on your like,
Oh shit,
here comes here.
Comes to so in the now and just react.
I mean like he was,
he's going to tell you is react thing.
Yup.
Wasn't thinking too much.
Well when he sent,
he tore up with that front kick.
Fucking God damn nasty,
nasty,
nasty.
But he just caught,
he caught something to Vito was doing,
if he toiled fight squared up,
you know,
he's always squared.
We were talking about earlier,
he always fought sorta squared up
because he would blitz guys and he always
wanted to be able to sprawl
and shoot and take you down.
So he had a very squared up style,
which made him open here and open here.
You know,
keep kicks.
Yeah.
Favorite.
Well remember when he fought John Jones,
John dropped him with the front
leg side kick to the body,
if you remember that.
I don't.
Yeah,
John John Recognize that Vito
was standing square as well.
And John hit him with a front leg side
kick right to the solar plexus and
dropped him.
Fuck.
And then Vituro caught
John with an arm bar.
Uber.
That fucking nasty,
super hyper extended his arm.
That's where I knew John
was something special.
Well,
I knew before,
but that's when,
uh,
in that fight I was like,
Jesus,
this guy has not given up.
His arm is fucked up.
How was it?
Are Gnarly,
dude,
I was squealing and v toward,
didn't let it go.
Man.
I mean,
he let it go.
Rather he didn't hold on to it.
John got out of it.
It's Craig in a fight again.
You think John,
I hope soon.
Who is kicking?
Alistair Overeem straight down the middle.
They were talking about his square
stance and they knew that would be open,
knocked out Alastair with
those front kicks in the UFC.
That's all.
Yeah.
I remember Greg Jackson
talking about that.
Travis got back from being
fucking badly hurt in that fight.
You remember that?
I mean,
Travis was battered in that fight.
His body was getting fucked up.
Allister was blasted him
in the body with knees.
Travis was almost out of
it and just gutted it out.
I still to this day feel like he
somehow or another missed his,
his path.
You know,
I feel like Travis,
when he was on,
when he knocked out Stephan Struve,
when you see,
when he was,
he used to fight different man.
He was switching around.
Yeah,
switched gyms.
When he's with Jackson's,
he was moving around a lot.
He was light on his feet
for whatever reason,
man.
Can you decided to switch gyms
and became more boxers style,
flat footed.
But I also think sometimes guys get to
the point where they just don't want to
do it anymore.
Or if they do want to do it,
they don't want to do it.
Like they used to want to do it.
They kind of want to do it.
Maybe they kind of want to pay day or
maybe they just want to win so they feel
better again.
And then they'll pump themselves up again.
And maybe I just get this one wind,
I'll get back on track.
But that,
that weird space of not knowing my,
uh,
my,
warrior am I looking to get out and my
look into that weird space is the worst
place it is.
It's the worst place.
Fight.
Fighting is just so fucking tough too.
You don't know what's going on.
You,
they could eat something.
They could have thought about
puke in the whole night,
could,
uh,
there's so much.
Yeah,
I can see that.
Girlfriend problems could
have family problems,
you know,
I mean,
but I feel like Travis at his best,
there was moments in his
career where I was like,
this guy,
I used to call them the dark horse.
I was like,
that guy's the dark horse
of the heavyweight division.
He might be the champ one day.
People are sleeping on him,
but the movement,
that guy had four fucking heavyweight.
He was,
he would see him switch and stances and
almost like TJ style movement flowing
again.
Giant dude,
man,
man.
Those deer legs when
they got going though,
Huh?
Yeah,
yeah.
That was a problem too.
Well,
that fight with our Lawsky.
That was probably when
I was convinced that,
you know,
like maybe like the best times
of past him because just,
I could,
first of all,
I guess him in our last few,
sparred a lot at Jackson's and our Lawsky,
although he's had a lot of wars and had
a lot of losses and been stopped a lot
of times.
You've got to remember
at one point in time,
our [inaudible] was a
real world class fighter,
a heavyweight champion who everybody was
terrified of when he knocked out Paulb
when Tello back in those days,
man,
he had a piston of a right hand just boom,
just throw it straight down the middle.
And he was still skillful guy.
So apparently in sparring he
would get the best of Travis.
So like when they got together,
like he had like serious
confidence in that fight.
That was a slobber knocker
do you remember that fire?
One round of full chaos.
Both guys got dropped.
It was one of the craziest one round
heavyweight fights of all time and our
Laskey wind up stopping them.
It's so,
it's so hard to pick those
heavyweight fights like any fight,
whoever lands first,
you never know.
Yeah.
Hey can I guess,
who do you think's gonna win?
It's like fuck.
Who the fuck knows?
What do you guys think of this?
Colby Covington.
A RDA fight this week for that Jack.
I hope RDA bust him up.
Well,
Colby is doing what you said.
You want to talk in a lot of Shit and
getting a lot of people paying attention.
I feel like he's,
he's doing,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
He's doing what he's doing.
It's paying people paying
attention for sure.
Beat Maya,
which is a huge accomplishment.
Right?
My is still an APP.
Absolutely.
World class fighter,
but other than that really hasn't beaten
big name guys and he's fighting for the
interim title.
You've got to think that a lot of that
is because he's been very smart with
promotion.
Telia had to hook.
Oh yeah man.
That's good.
Fuck.
That's going to be New Jersey for that.
I don't have anybody,
man.
I'm in that same what we just said.
Who the fuck knows?
Yeah.
I liked,
I liked the matchup though because Colby,
first of all,
Colby is not making one 55
unless he cuts a fucking leg off.
He's a bigger guy.
Rda was the 155 pound champion,
so you have to think.
Colby is going to have a size advantage.
Colby is a very good wrestler.
He's relentless and he
managed to do something that
very few people been able to
do with Maya where he'd
just overwhelmed him,
beat him up,
standing controlled where the fight took
place when a clear cut decision did it
in Brazil and did it after Woodley
did it and did it arguably better than
Woodley did it,
you know,
was on top of Maya.
It wasn't avoiding him in the
in a way that Woodley did,
but Whitley was injured in that fight.
He hurt his shoulder
like in the first round.
But it was an impressive performance.
I mean if you go back and watch what my
was able to do with like Rick story with
my has been able to do with Matt Brown,
Maya's a fucking monster
when he gets a hold of you,
it's such next level Jujitsu and Colby
was really never in trouble in that
fight.
So you have to look at that and you go,
okay,
well obviously he has fantastic defense,
solid wrestling base can strike on the
fee and knows how to like knows how to
fight a grimy,
nasty fight.
And he's the bigger guy.
But then you look at Rda and Rda at
lightweight was a fucking mauler was just
Merkin people.
Right?
But then you look at him at at
welterweight and you're like,
Jesus,
he might be better at welterweight.
Look how good he looked
against Neil Magni.
Everybody struggles with Neil Magni.
He smashed Neil Magni,
took them down,
leg kicked him,
dropped him,
get on top of them,
strangle him.
I mean,
he beat the shit out of Robbie Lawler.
The Robbie Lawler fight was crazy.
Like he just overwhelmed one of the best
strikers in the welterweight division.
Overwhelmed in from the outside
with angles and technique.
So it's interesting men.
It's very,
very interesting.
It's very interesting.
Some that aren't in Conor never fought.
I know.
I was so jack for the most exciting.
I was so excited for that fight.
Broke his fucking phone.
You know he's going to be a
problem for a lot of people.
Is that Gregor Gillespie?
Oh yeah.
Fucking do.
Oh yeah,
the gift foxing four time.
All American wa one time.
National Champ.
Sugar tougher and shit.
No holes this past weekend.
Yeah,
I was there.
Motherfuckers getting better and better.
55 yeah,
he's getting better.
He's a beast.
Yeah,
Dude.
He's relentless.
He's a beast.
Yeah,
he's,
he's fucking real solid,
real solid.
And,
and Scott that look,
you know,
just super,
super focused and tense.
You know,
there's just so much
talent right now in MMA.
It's just such a great time.
It's growing fast too.
Like watching the little
kid that the lab train.
I'm like,
Holy Yeah.
You'll see a little kids hitting a flying
armbars and shit and Benson Henderson
Sun.
It's going to be an animal.
Told Z he was he two to three.
He's throwing hooks,
smiling,
showed up,
legs
doing.
I don't know.
He's developing that way as a little kid.
Just from the time you're little,
your body's developing,
throwing punches and kicks
and then haven't bent.
And as your dad teaching your
mentality your whole life.
Fuck man.
Crazy.
Going to be so many.
Daisy put Benson to
sleep and shave his head.
A hub.
It's fucking hair's
always getting in the way.
He shaved his head,
just shave his head.
Just put,
put them under.
Just just put them on a day.
Wake up with a shaved head.
Come on man.
I know it's kind of your luck,
but the fuck outta here with that.
I was always doing this and
curled my hair last fight.
I know.
Look good.
God,
it's him.
Shit gets in the way.
It does.
And the constantly doing that.
I yeah,
liquid rose did.
She's like fuck.
He said fuck it.
Fuck I'm man,
she's a beast.
She's gorgeous too.
Yes,
she really,
and she doesn't play it up at all,
which is yeah.
Yeah,
she's cool.
Super honest.
It's going to be interesting
for who we get for sugar next.
Cause it's probably
gonna be a five rounder.
Well not what I was thinking.
Cause I'm originally
after that last fight,
after that last fight when
we went to the hospital,
the Ama,
the post fight conference,
Dana White took,
uh,
they said John's fight foot's fine because
at the hospital they said there was
nothing wrong with my foot
and the Dana Psych said that.
So I was thinking like,
oh,
okay.
I guess nothing drawn my foot.
I guess I'm going to fight because
they x rayed it with my foot up.
Not,
I get not flat on the surface.
Um,
so I suppose we're
going to fight July six.
I was going a headline
that card at us at a Sonia,
Sonia,
he's headlining that card.
I was supposed to I suppose to a headline
that car and I was so excited for
that.
Um,
so that because they
wanted me to headline,
but I think next fight is going
to be October 6th in Vegas,
the paper view.
Um,
hopefully you get to get on that card.
But then after that I would
like to headline my own.
Oh sweet.
So I would like to fight two more
times by the end of the year Hulings
everything's going good.
So I think October six
and then maybe November,
December.
So you sweet.
How do you decide when you're ready to go?
Full blast again with your foot.
Just bow.
Do you go to a doctor and
get it looked at again?
Get an MRI,
make sure everything's back in place.
Got A,
I got an x ray last time and
they said everything looks good.
Come back and four weeks
and we'll clear you.
But I'm really just,
I'm not going to listen to,
like,
I know how my foot feels like there's
days where it's really sore and there's
days I'm like,
dude,
it's good.
But I know it's just,
I feel like,
like I said,
about 80,
85%,
um,
and be like,
okay,
today,
today it's a little,
it was,
so we hit mits yesterday,
um,
and I lifted yesterday,
so it's a little bit sore,
but it's like a,
it's like a sore from not using it,
not like a sore from Osha injury.
Right.
So I think it's,
it's,
it's been Heelan.
Awesome.
I think everything,
I've been doing everything right.
So,
um,
I would say at three,
four more weeks,
I'll be ready to go 100%.
Did you see the Marlin Mariah's fight?
I,
I did.
I seen the highlight of it.
So it pretty much the whole
fight was the 34 seconds,
height ood beautiful switch switch kit
that much just because they're so like
the person has to be coming forward.
The distance and MMA,
so much different than
kickboxing and stuff.
We'll switch.
Cars aren't that great.
But man,
he,
I kids fucking lightning.
He's a bad motherfucker.
How tall is he?
Short.
Five.
Five or something like that.
You wouldn't be able to touch.
And Jimmy Rivera,
what is,
he's a little shorter than him.
They're both around the same side.
Five,
six in that range.
I'm going to give,
I'm going to give all these dudes trouble.
I'm just gonna be so long.
They're not going to get,
they're going to,
you can't train for you.
That's the problem.
We can't train for you cause
there's not many people can swim.
I love about going into
all my fights out there.
So confident and just cause I
feel like you can watch me on TV.
You can see,
oh yeah,
he's fast.
He does this,
does that.
We didn't tell him in front
of you and I'm doing it.
I feel like it's another,
another level of speed that they're not,
they they're not prepared for.
And I truly believe that like,
and I truly,
every fight that go into
that last fight I would,
I was 100% confident.
We're gonna knock him out.
I didn't knock him out,
but I,
if I had a couple more seconds in that
first round and you're so skinny and
goofy look and people on
people public fuck was sugar eyeball.
I'm like,
Hey,
remember that guy at our apartment?
We had our first apartment,
there's this big jacked
guy with a wife beater,
and we're like,
oh,
we're both professional fighters.
He's like that kid to
professional fighter.
He's like,
I don't want to be a professional fighter.
I'm like,
well,
he come spar sugar.
At the time I was working at the UFC gym,
I got a key.
He's like,
all right,
I'll be there fucking little
jack with wife beater.
I'm like,
okay,
perfect.
So sugar comes out,
Tito isn't gonna try to teat kicks him
right in the way and then ringing and I'm
recording it and the guy goes,
oh,
so sugars punching him and stuff.
Big Kick right to the guts.
Boom poop popel at his pants
in the ring and I wasn't,
I wasn't hitting him in the head hard.
I was,
I was conscious of,
I'm not trying to hurt this guy.
What did you train at all or
was he never dominant fighter?
I wasn't dying Jack Prison Guy.
Like,
like looked hard thought
after we weird boys after.
Yeah,
and it wasn't,
we were,
I wasn't being a bully.
We was like,
you want to smell like you sure.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
And it wasn't,
I didn't hurt him.
I did hit him with the
hard body kicking him.
He Shit himself.
But I wasn't,
I wasn't being a bully.
No,
not at all in the ring though.
And they smeared it all around.
So that smeared it all
around and we stepped on it.
They didn't know we didn't,
we didn't know.
We thought it was a dog.
Fuck.
Oh,
we thought it was a dog
we bought into the town.
Anybody that he shit himself.
No.
And I told him,
I was like,
dude,
Tony,
shoot yourself.
He's like,
no,
that wasn't me.
But I had it on my phone.
It was your wash the
poop out of assurance.
And then the boys smeared around,
but it's clean it up.
He didn't look and mopped it.
But it's funny,
like in public,
people always eyeball.
We're like,
what little bitch people are gross.
Yeah.
It was a lot of people out
there trying to chest puff.
I know.
Whatever.
Keep it moving.
Yeah.
Take care of folks.
Bye Bye.
Yeah.
Yup.
Stay out of trouble man.
You got a bright future.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I feel like I'm staying out of trouble.
No,
I feel like you are too.
It's sometimes trouble
gets in your way though.
Vegas,
Vegas.
I'm in a,
I've been there a few times.
Um,
when,
when my last time I went
to a pool party and it was,
it was dangerously fun.
I was like,
Oh shit,
I can't live here.
I can't fall.
I wanted to,
I had to like,
oh,
I've got a little buzz.
The women everywhere drinking,
dancing.
I'm like,
this is what he thinks.
Should we take a couple rips right now?
Okay.
Um,
I actually got a,
I got some sugar show.
Gee,
this is a,
you got it on you.
So this is going to be
for sale next Tuesday.
Yeah.
Who's making atrium?
California.
Um,
I met these guys,
so I met these guys in Fresno,
California.
We were there for our
buddy hot sauces fight.
Um,
I posted on Instagram,
I said,
hey,
does anyone some some weed?
I get
these guys messaged me.
They,
they came to me,
had like a,
a beautiful little setup
with some weed in it,
some cartridges and I was like,
damn,
these guys are good company.
There would be good kind of beginning to,
and they're super passionate about
wanting to get into the industry.
So then they made this and uh,
the industry meaning the MMA and
just like cannabis industry there,
they're going to be,
they have some,
they have six,
I think they won six awards
in the high times this year.
Um,
they're,
they're amazing.
I got you.
I got you some,
let me tell you something
about high times awards.
Let's say,
cause I was a judge at
one of the cannabis cups.
Nobody knows what the fuck sir.
Judging and everybody's a high out of
their mind is this is what they did the
day that I judged.
They gave me,
you never see one of them
pill boxes the people get,
whether it's like Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday,
and then like each one is like,
you know,
yeah.
Um,
each one of those had like a little label
on it and each one of them was like,
you know,
this is like fucking superstar.
Oh Gee,
this is death crack.
This is,
I dunno what the fuck I was smoking
by the time I was on the third one.
I was on another planet.
Man.
I mean it's a,
it's weird like,
like I had,
I had separated the membrane between this
dimension and the next and I was like
pushed through like trying to act normal.
Just trying to be nobody
who was acting normal.
Man.
It was real weird.
I'll never forget the conversations,
what I was having with
some of these people.
That is the fucking odd.
This the here,
here,
here's your own little joint.
This stuff's a cross between
Lemonhead in [inaudible] 92 it's cool.
It's a very,
is good.
The lemon,
but you know,
in this day and age,
man,
I feel like everybody's weed is good.
Yeah.
I can't remember was the
last time I found bad weed.
Yeah,
it's doesn't exist anymore.
Seriously.
A little ass trash tree
should be one lane here.
Oh,
perfect.
Yeah.
Seriously.
Day and age.
Who the fuck I was bad weed.
It's like,
it's everywhere.
Even you go all the way to New York.
New York is still illegal.
It's so strange.
We are friends.
Yeah.
My friend Ari lives in New York.
It's like you can get arrested
if you're smoking on the street.
Dude,
we were supposed to go to Singapore,
but not now.
They're not sending us their UFC.
I was going to go to Singapore for
the Singapore Card or Singapore.
Keep getting made fun of
for Santa Wrong Singapore.
Um,
but sorry to um,
they said that you can get tested
randomly off the street for,
for weed and you can go to prison.
Why so UFC decided not to send me,
wait a minute.
Who randomly tests you?
I don't know that my manager
called me and they said,
hey UFC at a little meeting they
said they decided not to bring,
they don't really want
you to go down there.
You can get tested randomly and
go to prison if you test for weed.
So
whoa,
yes,
we're not going but,
but,
but here's the reality.
That means that literally like 70% of
the UFC fucking roster could go out and
test it for weeding.
Yeah,
for sure.
All the coaches,
but what?
We're going to Canada,
I'm a,
I wasn't that funny man.
That's a thing about the
misconception about marijuana.
You know,
people think like,
oh stoners are lazy and it's like a
giant percentage of the UFC roster smoked
pot on a fairly regular basis.
I mean even NFL and sports in general.
Yeah.
Look,
I mean especially if you've got
injuries and you want to relax and CBD,
just CBD alone.
God Damn fucking everybody shoes that.
I have a buddy of mine,
my friend Aaron and he
was taking Ibuprofen.
He was taking it all the time.
I go,
man,
you got to listen to me.
He stopped taking that shit.
I go,
just get some CBD and just take it
orally and then also rub it on whatever's
bothering you.
And he did.
And he's like,
dude,
11 days,
no pain.
He goes,
I can't believe I've been taking this
fucking Ibuprofen forever and now he's
just taking CBD oil.
It's crazy.
Nothing,
nothing negative.
No,
it doesn't fuck your gut bacteria up.
It doesn't ruin your body,
doesn't get you high.
It doesn't do anything bad.
Rhonda goes off about Ibuprofen.
Doesn't she run a Patrick say,
yeah,
she was telling me how bad
it is for your gut bacteria.
Seriously.
Gut Bacteria.
I feel like it's one
of the most important,
obviously one of most important things
that people just don't really know about.
I think if I can tell,
if I take,
if I have enough probiotics for the day,
I can tell I got to hold.
It feels way better than if I don't.
I Love Camp Bucci.
You'll love it.
Drink it every day.
So try that.
New Watermelon flavor.
The gts kind?
No,
I only mostly have either the really green
one or the gingerade or the original.
Oh,
those are the original
trilogy is good too.
I liked that one too.
Sometimes like the grapes,
the grapes had a lot,
a little bit too much sugar in it,
I think.
Oh does it?
It's sweet if you look at
how much sugar is in there,
but still super,
super good for your body probiotics there.
So my friend Cameron Hanes is an ultra
marathon runner and he was heavily hooked
on Ibuprofen.
He was taking 800 milligrams a day,
sometimes more than once a day.
And uh,
I did the podcast with Rhonda and Doctor
Rhonda Patrick was going over all the
dangers of nonsteroidal antiinflammatories
and Ibuprofen and talking about the
increased risk of strokes and
all these different things.
And I called him up.
I go,
dude,
you got to get off that shit right now.
I go,
that stuff's terrible for you.
So here's where it gets crazy.
He gets off of it and all
of his pain goes away.
So the reason why he was taking
it was because he was in pain.
I'm good shit.
Seriously.
And,
um,
for him at least his,
the inflammation that it was causing him
probably because he's taking too much
as well.
You know,
a lot of people think like,
Hey,
it says take two,
I'll take sick.
Right.
And when you do that,
you're torching your fucking gut bacteria.
So he's creating all this
internal inflammation which
is in turn leading to all
this pain which has in turn
making want to take Ibuprofen.
Dan.
Yeah dude it and that's our
like lucky to have friends.
That was it as help each other like
mandatory drug testing in Singapore,
you can be dragged into custody without
a warrant and be compelled to submit to
drug testing by Singapore authorities
as Singaporean drug counselor and x
detainee.
Tony Tan explains for
the first time you're
caught or for drug
consumption are is one year.
The second time is three years and the
third time is five minimum with three
strokes of the cane says 10 consumption
just means that your urine has tested
positive.
We'd be heading to this Lillehammer
I ain't trying to go there dude.
I am not trying to go there.
I would not pump for the flight.
I've,
I've never been on a long flight and I
was not plump for that and I was pumped
to go and check it out and
they've been out of the country.
But here's a weird one with that.
Like how many weeks out
are we talking about?
Like consumption.
You mean if you test anything?
Yeah,
the article says that there's a lot of
Singaporeans that try to take drug trips
and they get caught when they come back
cause it's still in their system for
guys.
50 people,
50 people year to year,
a year in jail for drugs,
ecstasy,
anything sweet.
Oh my God,
that's terrifying.
Scary.
That's what we're dealing with.
I mean this is human beings.
2018 so you can live like we live here
in California where weed is legal and if
you're a grown adult,
just like you could buy a drink,
you could buy a joint,
which it should be.
It should have been a long time ago.
And then there's places where
they just put you in a cage.
North Korea.
Yeah.
Dude.
That shit is insane about,
cause they can't do they even,
they don't even have like
smartphones dressed stuff.
Right.
They don't have internet or
don't know what they have.
I think it should have some sort of a
small internet that only uses like North
Korea channels and shit like that.
I don't think they get
the regular internet.
Yeah,
dude,
they're living today under
the grip of a dictator.
It's so easy for us to bitch
about random stuff being here,
but we're so lucky.
Yeah.
Well how about the fact that the Korean
guy runs it is friends with Dennis
Rodman?
I know.
I was.
I was talking to my little brother
on about that the other day.
I was like really serious man.
He's friends with Dennis Rodman.
Like what the hell?
How fucking Dennis Dennis texted
real quick to see if he texted back.
That is fucking crazy.
That is fucking dentist's
parties with that dude.
Barney's like,
have you been to North Korea?
Oh yeah.
I think more than once.
Is that,
do they make,
what was that movie?
They make fun of North Korea dinner
with Dennis Rodman in that too.
Or No.
Oh,
that move money.
It seems like a big risk.
No,
I know.
I was thinking that too.
Yeah,
we probably shouldn't
talk about that movie.
Aren't they all have
in a meeting here soon?
Donald and the Korean
leaders to meet in Singapore?
Yeah.
That's what people were talking about.
The how dangerous it was to me.
To Singapore.
Dennis.
Rob,
no.
Be in Singapore during
Trump king summit sugar.
We got to get it on that.
Most of the are going to Singapore.
See there's some people that were
saying they shouldn't do it in Singapore
because Singapore is such a
horrible human rights record,
so some shit could be going down.
Yeah.
I don't see if Singapore really does
lock you up like that just for pot like
that is.
That is something that you want
to have a meeting with like,
but that doesn't make any sense.
Like that's an illogical
at the government.
These
people running under the grip of their,
they're living there.
There's less afraid of lies.
Right.
Like there are,
what are they afraid
of with this marijuana?
What do they think it's going to do?
What do you,
what do they,
what are they afraid of?
What people taking drugs open people's
mind like a little bit fact that they
think did they,
and they've made it so that they can
just lock you up in a cage if you do
something with your body that
they don't want you to do.
Look at him while,
because they've decided that this is some
sort of a bizarre form of dictatorship
that they can get away with.
Seriously.
Fuck man.
That is nuts that that's happening
while we're living here this way.
Trump,
Kim Singapore summit venue is set.
Trump who had a mommy,
the president,
who would want to be the president when
you're already a billionaire to imagine
the sit in on that fuck my life.
Didn't know.
The crazy thing is this dude has always
been this way and everybody's shocked
that he's this way now
that he's the president.
Right?
And it's not just that they're shocked.
It's just like,
it is shocking.
Like this Philadelphia Eagles thing,
like not enough of them wanted
to come to the White House.
So he canceled the meeting.
And so the thing,
they didn't kneel for the national anthem.
And so then if they find out that no,
those fucking guys,
none of them,
none of them kneeled
for the national anthem,
they all stood.
So he wrote,
he's trumps had something along
the lines of I fucked it up.
He said something along the
lines of that they didn't,
some of them didn't stand
for the national anthem,
but it turns out was only
one guy that kneeled.
And the one guy that Neil was cut before,
uh,
the regular season.
So during the regular season,
everybody was standing
for the national anthem.
So he said something,
it wasn't even true.
I just didn't want a small crowd of dudes.
He didn't want like three
dudes elec second stringers,
dawn old.
Looking forward,
you can tell her all high cause
they're melded all dry now.
Right.
So I'm the Philly,
the mayor of Philadelphia,
or is the governor of Pennsylvania,
which one was,
it was the mayor of Philadelphia.
Somebody went after him and he said what
a fragile ego he has that he couldn't
deal with not having a party.
We're enough Pete having a party
that people didn't want to go to.
It's just that that's,
that kind of shit is like part of him.
The show man,
like that's the act
that Trump the show man.
He's been involved in his whole life.
Right.
It's like everything he does is the best
and pumping everything up and we expect
differently now that he's the
president and that's where it's,
it's also strange because
this is just kind of,
people were really angry at it because
he's doing it as the president,
but this is like what he's always done.
He's like a branding genius.
Any,
it's weird because we're seeing
it as a president or likethis.
Is that what you're supposed to do?
You're not supposed to like
bend the truth as the president,
but like that bending of the truth in his,
in his eyes is always how he lived.
He was the Trump guy.
He's the fucking guy
who ran the apprentice.
Now he runs the country.
It's insane.
Fucking never followed politics
ever and I had no idea about,
I bet Paul P in any way thought
it was going to be like this.
Who had never signed up for it.
That's what I think.
So,
yeah,
man.
Not going the way you think.
Don't you think he would
bitch about it though?
Like bitch about it.
But that's part of his thing,
man.
The crazy thing is there was no one
on the republican side that was,
that was capable of challenging him.
That's the problem.
The problem was that
they didn't have anybody.
So there's all of a sudden this
guy's in there and I was in there.
He's probably thinking he's
going to lose and then you know,
he likes to win.
It's shit.
She's like,
God,
yeah,
fuck it.
I'm just going to be president.
And the next thing you know,
he is the president.
Nobody still the same guy,
man.
He's still the guy from the apprentice.
That's not his fault.
It's who he is.
To ask a guy to change that much.
It's 70 it's crazy.
I think the best thing about it is it
highlights how ridiculous this whole
process is and the idea of having
one person run 300 million people,
that's insane.
And you pick that person,
it's insane.
And we don't even know what we're doing.
Are we even picking?
No.
Well,
we don't even know what we're doing.
How much of what we pay and how much of
like what the bills are about and all
these amendments.
I'm I,
how much of any of that shit do you pay
attention to when Congress is in session
at the Senate rules on things,
how much do we pay attention?
How much does everybody pay attention?
How much do you even know what
someone's actual real policies are?
At least their stated policies.
When you're voting for him,
what is it like 10% people?
Seriously.
You know,
like you hear who you're
supposed to vote for know,
vote for Hillary Clinton is
Donald Trump's a bad person,
you know,
vote for Hillary Clinton.
She's the most qualified for the job.
You're like,
okay,
yeah,
that sounds about right.
And people are like,
you are voting for Hillary Clinton,
aren't you?
She's the most qualified for the job.
You're like,
okay,
yeah,
I want to be a good person.
Some of the vote for Hillary.
What about Jill Stein?
You know Jill Stein's a woman to,
you know Jill Stein is brilliant.
You know Joel Stein's Okay Shit,
I'm going to go progressive,
but her stand,
I told Jill Stein
and then there was Elizabeth Warren
might've lied about being part of American
Indian.
That was a problem.
So it was like,
like who who's going to go is Bernie
Sanders and then all that shit to him and
Hillary Clinton is that the
whole story is so bizarre.
Like watching it all play out on TV.
It's so strange.
It's so strange that this is our,
our form of government
like you would think with,
this is my thought.
You would think with the kind
of things that the organism,
that is a human being,
the kind of thing that could figure out
a way to make sound go through a metal
thing covered in foam goes through wires
and in real time hits people in their
ears.
If they're streaming,
they could have headphones on beyond
the train right now and they're getting
this in real time that we can send
video through the sky and it can hit
Australia.
Your friends can text you pictures
back and forth from Africa.
They could be in Africa and
dude,
I just saw a leopard and they send
you a fucking photo and you're like,
Holy Shit,
that's flying through the sky.
And yet the best way we can figure out
who's in control of the nuclear weapons
is to have a popularity contest.
No word for crazy.
Where the craziest thing,
God,
it's not,
we're like,
we're in like this wave of like being
evolved and not being involved at the same
time,
like technologically spectacularly evolved
to the point where we can bend matter
and create nuclear weapons and fly robots
to Mars and take pictures and send it
back to us.
Like the shit that we can do is off the
charts when it comes to like technology
and our ability to manipulate the world
around us and create giant buildings and
structures and airplanes
and bridges and shit.
But the,
the monkey interaction thing
is still not very good.
So we still have war.
We still have places where we send
people over with metal tanks and guns and
shoot people and protect people from the
other people that are shooting people
and get involved in all these fucking
crazy things are physical interactions as
as organisms are just still
in this barbaric stage.
We're still in this one tribe going after
another tribe stage from 20,000 years
ago,
30,000 years ago.
It's like the same programming,
but now this programming can fly jets
filled with missiles and shoot them out of
the sky and sneak up on you
underwater in a metal tube,
a summary and it shoots fucking nuclear
with missiles and shit underwater.
I mean,
we're in the weirdest flux.
We're in this weird sort of unbalanced
period in the evolution of the human
organism cause we can do so much
and then put Donald's in charge,
man about fucking everything.
We're mad about men who decide they're
women who want to use the girls' room.
We're mad about everything.
We're about,
about religion.
We're mad about rights
and gender and everything.
Everything.
We're mad,
everyone's mad.
Fuck rose have bar.
Everyone's mad.
Everyone is so mad.
And while all this is all this weird
personal interaction shit is happening,
that's distracting the fuck out of us.
The more it ramps up the,
the better.
Ai gets our foot artificial intelligence
because it gets just keep working on it
and keep getting better and better.
We're going to be in like a full
on rock fight when AI goes live,
it's like,
it's like we're,
we're falling into this whole
like if this was a trap,
if I was artificial intelligence
and I knew how to be like,
well as what we'll do,
we'll just go back in time and set
people up and make them make us,
we'll just plant this idea in their heads
and just like an aquatic worm makes a
caterpillar or one of those grasshoppers
rather jump into a pool and drowned
itself so that it could
swim out of its brain.
You ever seen one of those
things happen just like that?
Ai's doing that with us.
They give us Shiny Samsung Galaxy note
nine look at how big the whole pottery is
and he takes photos of your
face and knows your face.
You can tell your face.
Yeah.
Face ID and fingerprints.
And before you know it,
listen,
we've found the best way to get a
signal to talk to people doing that.
You just stick it in your ass.
It's a little pellet.
We're gonna put a little
robot Dick in our ass,
a little pepper.
The appellate.
If you could just hold in your ass,
it's smooth.
Do you barely know what's in there?
But it connects with your,
your ass is open.
It's not like the rest of your skin
and y'all got to keep it in your mouth,
right?
Well,
to asses the way to go
cause it's like open.
You know,
it's not like you don't have to go
through the dermis and so that just just
connects with you and you can
fucking see augmented reality.
But the little tiny robot dick,
it's about that big.
You barely feel it.
It's like a BB.
Uh,
that's what's going to happen,
dude,
fucking prior.
Right?
Do these things are growing
now our anti-aging shit too.
Who knows how crazy that's going to get.
I think what the weirdest thing is,
not the anti aging.
I think we're going to run
into biological limitations.
I think the weirdest shit is gene editing.
Fuck yeah,
let's just solve this.
Took a turn for the stoner
gene editing scares the shit out of me.
Was that unexplained on the,
explain that new necklace,
Netflix show,
gene editing and how,
how,
how did he,
that Shit's going to get wild,
wild country.
I only watched the first episode,
but I was like,
Holy Shit,
I see where this is going
to follow show baby.
Fuck everyone.
The man.
As far as that out,
and I'm like,
it takes a turn,
but I'm sure he still had good intentions.
I think trying to build the community,
I'm just passionate and this is,
again,
this is the thing,
it's the fucking human interaction part
is the part that we can't get right.
It's real weird.
If you look at all the different kinds
of interactions that we managed to
successfully navigate and people have
obviously have problems in business and
there's lawsuits in business and there's
people that get fired and there's all
sorts of problems with
people doing business.
But overall they get a
lot of things done right?
Like business keeps improving.
Things keep getting better.
We barely improved with
how we treat each other,
like the way human
beings treat each other.
We barely get better at that and
we do react to things better.
Like if we're mad at
someone for doing something,
that's where we would like more clear
with like agregious violations of our
code.
Right?
Like racism.
Like this Roseanne thing was a big one,
right?
Everybody was like,
no fucking way.
We're not tolerating that.
Fuck her.
And the ABC's like Yo fuck it.
We're pulling the plug on the show.
It's like,
like immediate reactions.
So it's like what I,
what I'm co,
I don't think it was right.
I think she's got a lot of problems and
she's taken a shit load of pills and
she's all fucked up and
I know she's not racist.
At least she tells me that.
But what I do know is that racism is
horrible and people just don't want to
tolerate it anymore.
And that's what the good thing is.
The good thing is like this,
right?
There's overwhelming response from
people that they're not tolerating racism
anymore.
You can't
do that anymore.
We won't tolerate it.
And this is fairly new man.
I mean w with the civil rights marches,
that was in the 60s right?
I mean think about what was going on
in the 50s and the forties and fed that
shit.
That was not that long ago in terms
of like how long there's been people.
So we're dealing with this
radical change in this regard,
but very little change in like
our kindness to each other.
That's why did start the American
mushroom day or not the American,
the worldwide are you should fear has
a holiday that he created called true
fest.
Yeah.
It's several days are,
doesn't fuck around.
Got a real job since he was the
doorman at the comedy store.
He operates on its own schedule.
That's,
that's what it's going to take for
something like that worldwide to change.
It'll certainly help cause shrimp fest
festival certainly out she's room to
help.
I'm promoting that,
but I feel like I'm,
part of it is because we're scared.
I legitimately feel like we're scared.
And I think when someone
like Trump is in office,
we're more scared because we
realize how easy it is for,
uh,
you know,
I hate to use a term regular person cause
he's definitely not a regular person.
He's very successful and very famous
and everybody knew who he was,
but regular person turns that we don't,
that's not how it
politician acts like that.
This is like some crazy show man.
And when a crazy show man
becomes the leader of the thing,
whether or not he's doing good is,
I'm not even arguing politically whether
he's doing good or bad or the economy's
up because of him,
I don't know.
But it's just how he behaves.
It's who he is like that
that freaks people out.
And that makes people more on edge
and so they're more angry and they're,
they're,
they're more looking to call people out
on things and they're more looking to
stomp out racism.
I get it.
And making other people would think if
someone like Sam Harris was a precedent
or something and he was talking
about a national mushroom day,
are talking about that stuff,
how bad people would freak out.
Seriously,
they would freak.
Or are they just people
that disagree with Sam too?
You know,
there's a ton of re very,
very smart people that disagree with Sam.
You know,
and it's really interesting to see those
disagreements cause when really high
level intellects debate each other about
things or disagree on things and you
get to see not just their ideas play
out and how their ideas work against the
other person's ideas.
You get to see that.
But you also get to see like thinking and,
and,
and communicating at a super high level,
right?
They're intellectuals are
trying to outsmart each other
so that they're debating
about the existence of God
or whatever the fuck it is.
When you get really smart
people who disagree on Shit.
Very fascinating.
It's like one of the more
interesting things to watch.
So like a lot of ways,
high level Jujitsu,
you know,
and a lot of ways you're watching like Oh,
okay.
And those guys,
a lot of them get into
g like is in a Jujitsu,
is he?
Yeah.
I think that's one of the
reasons why he's into it.
It's cause he's kind of
doing Jujitsu when he's,
when he's doing these debates.
Yeah.
Damn man,
I want my little brother
to do it so bad he won't,
won't try it.
Wow.
It's probably hard.
His brothers of fucking
MMA star and he's like,
yeah,
I know,
but alone shit bro.
He could,
it could be as passionate.
They get me to have a
passionate and I'm like,
dude,
you could try to get through and you
know the people first smart people.
I think it's the support.
I'm like,
dude,
you could be so good
at Jujitsu and love it.
It is very smart.
There's a lot of super smart.
Eddie always calls him his nerd assassins.
Super Smart dudes that are
really good at Jujitsu.
Scary.
Good.
I think like getting a black
belt from someone goods,
one of the hardest degrees out there
to get in any college or anything
physically.
The thing about college is if you put
in the work and you're smart enough,
it's possible.
I mean,
you can do it.
it's a possible achievement.
A lot of people have done it.
A lot of people do it every year,
but to really get a black belt bull,
you gotta get,
you gotta get better.
Like you got it.
You have to get back,
you gotta get strong,
you're going to get choked a lot.
And how were you built or you
built normal like a small,
if you're small,
you're extra super fucked.
Right?
How's your ego?
Yeah.
Can you learn?
Do you know how to tap?
Because if you don't tap,
you're going to get hurt.
Like almost every significant
injury I ever got doing Jujitsu,
other than like one fucked up knee was,
which was just a weird
passing the guard thing.
My,
my ACL popped.
But almost every other one
was from not happening.
Yeah,
just just decide you're not going to tap.
I'm going to try to get out of this.
I'm gonna try it.
And someone's got unit Doris or something
like that and your shit's all fucking
cracked over and then for the next week,
ah,
you get that tightness in
the middle of your back.
Like why didn't I just tap?
I should have just tapped.
John Crouch always told me,
he's like,
dude,
you're just so tough
when you get submissions.
People can't tap you out,
but I want you to just
focus on not getting there.
So when you get there,
just tap right away.
Just focus on not getting there.
It's very smart because you know what,
you're always going to be tough.
And there's a certain,
I mean you need to know a certain
amount of high level defense.
Like how can you,
how long can you survive in a certain
spot if you actually have to survive.
But in training you're
not really surviving.
Right?
You're just,
you should just tap sometimes.
Oh yeah.
Especially with Nishit
and arm shit and you know,
you pop something and then
it's fucked for six months.
That's where we're going to be focused
on a lot with Sean is a lot of legs and
heal hooks and the bars,
the lower half of the body who you guys
are working with that on a Gusto Mendez
to Keanio yeah.
Yeah,
super high level.
It's fun.
They hit,
they have competition roles.
It's like all the black belt,
like what are the six,
seven,
six,
seven black belts and we
do a 10 minute rounds.
Usually Tim go back.
It's fun.
That leg lock game is hitting an extremely
high level right now in Jiu Jitsu and
now trickling into MMA.
You know Dylan Dannis like
the way he looked in Beltour I think
slowly in MMA it's going to be tough
because a lot of spots you're getting
punched and then one punch solid punch in
the right spot changes their game.
It puts a little fear in their mind.
So then for sure,
but if those guys can you
get good enough to strike,
to become a threat,
like a guy like Gary Tonin,
whoo.
That's scary.
That's a scary dude.
It really is very scary man.
Cause he gets a hold of that leg.
Urine [inaudible] bowls,
sons and steps ahead.
That Donna,
her death squad man,
Donna,
hers are real wizard man.
So when we get him a hat with stars on it,
a little moons and stars,
he's a wizard zone who studied philosophy
like that and this is a type of person
like that.
It's fucking pretty cool.
Yeah.
And that's shit that he wrote should
read that thing that he wrote about
routine.
It's really interesting.
It's a lot of really cool,
smart shit.
Check it out for sure.
His Instagram was filled with cool,
smart shit.
Yeah,
that's awesome.
He's got a DVD series out now,
a leg lock series.
He shot it and he didn't like it all.
So he reshot it.
This Reshad at him.
Yeah.
Damn.
That's pretty cool.
Yeah,
it's going to be,
it's going to be funny to see
how far those leg luck game.
We'll go and him and maybe before we
evolve more and then find the counter to
that.
It's like,
well,
what's interesting to me is that this
is essentially all out of a conversation
that he had with Dean lister.
You know,
and it's become a meme now.
It's really funny.
There's a photo of a girl
lying in bed and she's like,
he's probably thinking about
another woman and the guy.
I said,
yeah,
why would you ignore 50% of the day?
We bought it,
and I love how John Danaher said it too.
He says,
why would you,
why would you ignore
50% of the human body?
And we're like,
wow,
it makes you uncomfortable around.
He's super smart.
That's awesome.
You know?
He's like,
if you're a blue belt and
he wrote with a black belt,
you always feel a little
weird around them.
That's how I feel.
Random intellectually,
not just physically,
but they like,
oh,
okay.
Can you tell me what it is?
I'm not arguing with you,
man.
She said,
John,
take a puff of this.
Does he get hired on?
I don't know,
man.
Probably doesn't have to.
Probably can do it to his own brain.
I'll just put myself
in a perfect position.
You wonder if someone
like Elon Musk gets high?
I would hope so.
Holy Shit.
Fuck that guy is on another level.
It's aren't they building those
tunnels already under la or they build,
oh man,
they got their building that
he's got a boring company.
They're gonna bore holes through La and
reinforce them and you're going to go
through on sleds.
I think they're all like
getting done right now.
Dude.
I do not want to be in one of those things
and hear the rumble of the earth and
see the ocean.
Russia
as tsunami hits the tsunami hits
while you're in one of those pipes.
I wonder if it got out
of that and your butt's
coming from the middle of the ocean.
Just
good.
Paul's back and thousands of fucking
miles of the earth had been torn apart.
That shit's happened to gang at times.
Seriously.
I
never knew that shit has happened
many times where the cowboy,
what happened in Fukushima
has happened a ton of times.
We're just,
we don't live long.
So these things,
they'd seem like they're forever,
but it's based on our lifespan.
Our lifespan is so weird cause it's,
it's really short.
You know,
and it seems like it's not because
you're in the middle of it,
but if you look at it objectively,
you're not.
No one makes it out alive and it doesn't
take that long for your body to give
up.
So by the time you start figuring things
out and getting your shit together,
you're already old falling apart.
And all the while we're dealing
with a planet whose time is,
is almost infinite,
right.
For in,
in terms of like what we can understand.
So all these things that
we know have happened,
even if we study supervolcanoes and
tsunamis and cataclysmic earthquakes and
solar flares,
even when we study all those things,
man,
we don't think they're real.
They're like,
yeah,
but it's,
you know,
it's Guatemala.
It's only happened in Guatemala.
Yeah,
it's Hawaii.
But Hey,
they knew they're on an island.
We can't control this thing when he
houses because we don't think very good
because we don't realize that we,
this might not be here in a year,
there might come a giant wave that
hits those fucking houses are perched.
And Santa Monica perched over
the water and Malibu and shit.
But what are you doing?
How are you still confident
that water's not going to move?
Ah,
cause it hasn't moved in 30 years.
That's a second.
No,
in the life of the earth.
30 years is a second.
Yup.
You put your house on the edge of an
alien world that moves back and forth and
there's one contractor
who made that decision.
It'll hold up.
Well these guys just decide,
right?
I want to,
I want to wake up in the morning cause
I'm a winner and I want to do my coffee
and I want to do my coke and I want to
look out the window and see the fucking
Ojai money money by then.
Yeah.
Super amped up.
Aderall dude's trying to run
the world staring at that water.
It looks great.
Fuck yeah.
Can I ask how can I have water?
Everyone's looking at them
like they got it figured out.
What?
Oh my God.
Luxury home teeters on
collapsing off cliff.
So that cliff gave up in the house
is still there in Texas actually.
Oh is it really?
Oh,
is that Austin Fort Worth?
Oh Damn.
Look at that one right above it.
Yo.
You've got to fix that.
Whoever the contractor is,
you get into,
oh,
are you sure
Jamie is real?
I was thinking,
oh my God,
that's what Cooper looks fake as fuck.
Who would trust that fucking shitty idea
of a house hanging off the edge of a
cliff?
Whoa.
Look at that thing.
That's
beautiful.
Is that real futuristic shit that
looks fake her than this one?
This one might be real.
Oh Wow.
He parks his car on top of that.
What have you heard or
know the night here?
They're like,
oh my God,
we gotta get the fuck off the house,
honey.
We're drawing down.
Wait,
wait.
I can't find my phone.
Let Ricky grab his iPad.
He'll
look at you running off in the distance,
holding the baby under your arm and you
fucking see the house fall off the side
of the cliff.
Polo.
Boom.
It is real.
It's real Australia.
Oh my God.
People are crazy.
You couldn't smoke.
I get too paranoid.
Australians don't give a fuck.
They don't give a fuck.
Oh,
is that an Australia?
Those are,
those are exceptional humans.
It's sweet.
I'm a big fan of the Australians.
Might be fake.
Really.
Right.
I found an article that looked like it
said it was real and then I just looking
for more and it says it my,
like Google said fake after it.
Oh,
well,
sorry.
You know,
it's funny,
uh,
switching subjects,
but like seeing people that are married,
husbands that are married to their wife,
just going through the,
the classic role of get married and you
got your wife and you don't talk to her
and go to the boys series explained.
Yeah.
That's a good one.
Did you watch that at all?
Explained?
No.
Who's doing that one?
I'm not sure who's doing that one,
but it talks about all that stuff.
Like how,
um,
monogamy with creative.
Yeah.
How males aren't made for monogamy.
They're just not all humans
are built more for a,
I explained.
Yeah.
Well that's probably based on my friend,
Dr Chris Ryan's book,
which is sex at dawn,
which is what,
is that what it's based on?
Yeah.
It mentions in him.
Oh,
he's in.
He's,
yeah.
Yeah.
He's a big proponent of that idea,
which is very,
it makes a lot of sense.
If you look at the way chimps behave,
right?
We were the cousins of chimps,
chimps.
Fuck everybody.
Everybody fucks everybody.
So the idea is like,
how did we get to a place where
everybody stopped fucking everybody in?
Somewhere along the line in evolution,
it's shifted.
Whether it's the cultural evolution.
Yeah,
there's a lot of theories,
man.
There's a lot of theories.
Check.
Terence Mckenna had some
weird ideas about it.
His theories were all drug based.
He all,
he felt there was a mushroom thing.
He felt like a climate change caused
people to move from a mushroom culture to
an alcohol culture.
And that the,
the death of the ego and the expanded
consciousness and the community,
uh,
feelings that you would get
from communal mushroom trips,
all were replaced by
Drunkin assholeishness and,
and chaos.
And you,
he really breaks it.
He broke it down.
He's not alive anymore,
but when he was alive,
he broke it down pretty eloquently.
And you know,
it's not something I'm smart enough to
know if he's right or if he's wrong,
but it's a very compelling
argument that people,
because we know that they used to
definitely do a lot of mushrooms.
They knew,
we know the Vikings
did a lot of mushrooms.
We knew that.
We know that there's a bunch of ancient
art pieces that show mushrooms and even
people that were under
the spell of the mushroom,
like a person,
like a really old one,
Jack Hara was showing all the bs.
Jack Hara was his great.
We'd activist,
uh,
who,
wrote a book called the emperor has no
clothes and saw a book about him being a
Goldwater Republican and finding marijuana
and then becoming like this marijuana
advocate and be in a hero for marijuana.
And he was in the middle
of writing a book.
Um,
and part of the book was about mushrooms
and Mushrooms in the history of
Christianity.
And he had all this ancient artwork
that was all had mushroom iconography,
like mushroom images in it.
And he was like,
the shit was everywhere.
He unfortunately had a stroke
and then wound up dying.
He was a great man and in the world of uh,
marijuana,
he's certainly hero risky,
risked his neck like way,
way early on and you know,
stood by his beliefs and can talk,
cut a lot of shit for his book,
but also got a lot of
love for how he stood for,
you know,
a guy opening up as mine and changing his,
mind me,
he was a staunch Republican.
They started smoking pot and became this
crazy pot advocate and his next thing
was about mushrooms.
Man,
how awesome is that?
And there's some immune,
there's a lot of stuff out
there that you can read.
The,
it was a lot of good articles online
where people have shown there's ancient
images of Adam and Eve from a fresco
and France from like a long fucking time
ago.
See if he could see that mush,
Adam and Eve mushroom fresco,
just like you were saying,
John,
you're like,
how do we know?
Like some of that Bible wasn't
people writing stories on mushrooms.
Oh yeah,
sure.
Well,
there's a lot of people that believe
it's entirely possible that that's the
case.
There was actually a recent
scholar from Jerusalem that,
thanks,
you see,
this is the image that's Adam and eve
and look at those mushrooms and not even
mushrooms.
Iowasca for those Bible stories.
It's like,
holy fuck.
Who knows?
I mean,
who knows when they
figured out Iowasca right,
and who,
who got ahold of it?
We know that they had it in South
America thousands of years ago.
We don't,
we don't know how many thousands though.
Apparently.
It's really hard to figure out.
But look at that image.
13th Century Fresco depicting an Adam
and eve and the tree of knowledge.
That tree appears to be modeled
after an ama to miscarry a mushroom.
Oh,
whoa.
This is the tree of knowledge.
I mean,
dude,
this is from the 12 hundreds right?
So this is,
this is closer to the bone than the
original story than we are now in terms of
is,
I don't know,
I think there's something on the
ballot in California to legalize it.
God,
I hope they do.
Even if they just do it for therapy.
Seriously.
Yeah.
Just there's a lot of these old old
pictures that have mushrooms in with a
religious icons.
It's real weird,
man.
Like think of this Jesus
with mushrooms and his feet.
There's a bunch of crazy,
there's a bunch of these
really old weird picking it,
but the thing is like
what is it evidence of?
Is it evidence that mushrooms were
involved in the creation of Christianity?
Possibly,
but it's also evidence that artists do.
Yeah.
For Real,
man.
You're a fucking guy.
He's a paid her back then.
Maybe you're doing mushrooms all the
time and you want to put the mushrooms in
everything.
We don't really know what I mean.
Especially if he's doing mushrooms and
nobody else even knows what they are.
He's like,
listen,
this is one of the,
but I gotta I gotta think that everybody
knew about him back then and they
probably shared them with
people that they cared about.
Because if you lived in a world with,
just think of it this way,
you lived in a world with no media.
You have no books,
you have no science.
You have stories,
you have a crude language.
You write things down,
you draw things.
There's no TV shows,
there's no cars,
there's no nothing.
There's no history of history
of talking about shit.
You wouldn't you think
if you found mushrooms,
if your life suck that much ass like
this is the world you're living in his
barbarian's everywhere and you'd get
fucking step on a thorn and you get
poisoned in your body and you die
because no one has antibiotics.
You get an infection from a cut,
you're dead.
I mean this is,
this is how people existed back then.
Do you think if they
found mushrooms that they,
they wouldn't cherish them like that?
Someone would somehow under
the demonize them for real.
Seriously.
If they had nothing else,
why would they demonize mushrooms?
They demonized it after
they figured it out.
After they figured out like,
hey,
like they probably went
big gaps without having it.
That's the theory.
They probably don't like big gaps where
mushrooms weren't apart of culture
anymore and then people
tried to reintroduce them,
but culture had already gone in
this weird sort of violent champ.
Alcohol,
amphetamines way.
Damn,
damn,
fuck,
fuck.
Oh
yeah.
It's not like we're making something up.
Like this is some Alice in wonderland
book where there's some medicine that says
drink me and if we drank we are
going to go on this journey.
Yeah.
That's just a book.
Mushrooms are real and they're everywhere.
Yeah.
I mean there's parts of the country they
just fucking grow and constantly it's
Praysee w when you talk about people that
were living in it back in that day and
how tough it was,
you wonder if they had dislike as much
happiness as we have if there are more
positive thinking or what?
I don't know what I mean.
Like it's a good question because
they didn't know any better.
They might have had a more,
it's like this guy that wrote this book,
Jesse Itzler this,
this book is in front of
you living with a seal.
He also wrote a book,
uh,
living with monks and he was,
he was just here and he just,
uh,
was talking about it was really
fucking interesting shit man.
Damn,
I bet.
Really interesting shit.
Yeah.
But one of the things he
was telling me was like,
how happy these guys are.
They're just meditate all day.
They just do their job.
They train dogs and they meditate all day.
That's crazy.
It was like they're all
really happy and he was like,
how many people do you think in
the real world are really happy?
I'm like,
I don't know.
And he said,
60 something percent.
Would you say 67 67% or how
they got a happy or unhappy?
Unhappy.
Yeah.
67% are unhappy.
Oh,
I'm sure.
Fuck duty.
Even that,
I'm like,
whoa.
Really?
Like there's what?
33% people happy.
That's more than I expected.
She truly,
that are truly happy,
truly happy doing what
they want every day.
Yeah.
There's not,
that's hard.
God,
I'm so,
yeah,
you lucky or super,
super lucky.
Anybody out there that's listening,
it's doing what they want.
Whether you're making furniture or
painting pictures or singing songs,
what are the fuck you're doing?
If that's what you really
want to do and you're happy.
Yeah.
You gotta pay it back.
And even if you're not making a fortune,
no,
you listen.
If you're getting by
and doing what you like,
it's so much better than being rich,
doing what you hate because your time is
what's so valuable when you know if you
have a job and you hate it,
but it gives you a lot
of money and you say,
well,
I'm going to get out of it eventually.
The problem is that time that you
need to do that job at eight hours,
that's a giant chunk of your day,
but a lot of people
don't have passions too.
What would they be doing?
Those was eight hours a day.
A lot of people don't even know.
They look like my dad gets
off work and goes to work.
He's like,
what is he doing?
You know,
what do you want to get good at?
What do you,
what are you passion about?
What do you want to do?
And it's easier for like this newer
day and age to look on the Internet and
learn things on the Internet and
see people on the Internet doing.
I'd be like,
oh,
they're doing it.
I'm not doing it in our
parents' generation.
They didn't have that.
Everyone did it and they had no,
it was rare.
You're super lucky if you
find a passion that you,
gosh,
at a young age and back
then everybody was scared,
right?
So they would always tell people don't,
don't do that.
Don't take any risks,
play it safe.
Get that good job.
You know,
they're given benefits.
You'll get your degree,
play it safe,
you know?
Well if you have a degree
then you'll have to,
you'll definitely have a backup plan.
You know,
you want to have a safety net.
Everyone back then was,
their parents had been in
the fucking depression.
Man.
Even when I had grown up,
people are kind of telling me like,
no,
you're going to fight for like,
what are you gonna do for work?
How many 50 year olds do you know that?
Like you want to see and be like,
man,
I want my life.
Like there's like someone like
you or Paul check like you got,
it seems like at your
age that's pretty rare.
People fall apart and what
they want the ride is it's,
you know,
everybody can,
if you've watched one of
those mechanical bulls,
it was Wa watch when people do start
ramping it up the beginning everybody can
hang on everybody hang on.
But as life gets more and more
complicated to get older and older,
your body starts failing.
You got to stay on your exercise program
or you feel yourself to tea where
you're rating.
Like you've realized like
how long can I keep this up?
How long can I keep this going?
You know?
And and also people who have been doing
what they don't want to do for 20 years
now waiting to retire 25 years.
Yup.
To me,
my number one for sure,
the most fortunate thing is the
people that I'm friends with.
And then I love my family and
people I'm close to though.
I'm close to a bunch of really positive
people that have similar mindsets to
yours about eating healthy and taking
care of yourself at that for sure.
Also about being nice.
That's salt,
that's real important.
Being around a bunch of people that are
cool to each other and then to doing
what I want to do.
Cause I didn't do what I
want to do and I've looked,
I don't want to anybody to cry
for me that I was on fear factor.
It's not like it was a bad job.
I would've taken it again in a heartbeat
if I was in the same situation.
It was great.
You know,
it's,
it offered me money,
a lot of money to do a show that
wasn't anything I wanted to do.
Like it wasn't a sitcom,
it wasn't doing standup comedy.
It was this weird thing,
but it was a great job.
Like I'm not,
I'm not hating on it,
but it doesn't feel the same way.
Even though I'm very
thankful that I got that job.
It doesn't feel the same way as it would
if I was say doing a podcast or doing
standup or just doing
whatever I want to do.
We're not off to what I have to.
I don't have to do something
just because it's my job.
Instead,
I do it because I actually like to do it.
You don't have to watch your p's and
q's all the time cause you're in the
corporate world and be watching yourself.
Man.
I mean,
I fuck up all the time.
I say stupid things all the time.
If people are like,
why'd you say that?
Am I because I'm free ball and I'm say
things off the top of my head for hours
at a time or a case.
Yeah.
Occasionally I'll say something stupid.
I take a swing and a miss.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
ultimately it's,
you know,
I'm,
I'm going to try to police
myself as best as I can,
but it's just so much better
than having to piece somebody.
It gives you a chance to
get better at your own shit.
You know,
whatever you're doing,
if you can work for yourself or figure
out a way to do the thing that you really
want to do,
it gives you a chance to get better
at the thing that interests you.
The thing that's fascinating.
Yeah.
Mean
to you.
Yeah,
it's pretty sweet.
It's super lucky.
When I was,
when I first moved to Arizona,
I had,
I didn't have to work,
I'd like sponsored local
sponsors back in Montana.
Um,
um,
this thing bar the one,
give them a shout out this thing.
Uh,
Elliot Smith and Jones labs construction.
Yeah.
Their lunch.
That just for a small town
companies that work and I,
I was able to put all of my time
into learning how to eat healthy,
learning how to use my brain and training.
Like I got to use all my time for that.
I was so lucky for that.
And,
and it's not,
it's huge for young fighters,
you know,
getting a cool business and what's to put
their logo on your shorts or something
like that.
That's where we benefited
from coming from a small town.
We racked up a lot of experience.
Like in Phoenix there's amateur fighters
that they can't get fights for the life
of them.
We could fight every
weekend if we wanted to.
So we got a lot of re reading
experience and got comfortable in there.
Yeah,
there's a crazy Midwest circuit,
right?
Like,
that's why Jeremy Horn has over a
hundred fights and Travis Fulton was,
he have like 200 plus fights.
Crazy like that,
but a lot of those dudes,
you mean you could literally
fight constantly all the time?
Yup.
I fought three weekends in
a row once I remember that.
That's nuts.
But don't you get super
loose when you do that?
You get like used to it.
Yeah.
The experience is different,
right?
It feels normal.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
I remember going into like bigger fights
and people would kind of thing to get
anything there.
I was like,
I don't think I will.
I just don't get like before
if I don't feel nervous,
I'm,
how do you feel?
I feel calm.
I feel like I feel like I'm just calm,
just ready for,
I'm just waiting for,
I feel like I'm really the now and
I'm just waiting for to get there.
I'm just,
what are you thinking about?
I'm,
I feel calm.
I don't know.
It's just super confident.
I know.
Like I,
in my head,
I'm going in there,
I'm going to knock this dude out.
Whether I do or don't.
That's what I'm,
that's what every,
every fight I get into.
I'm going in there thinking I'm gonna
knock this dude out every fight.
And I truly feel that,
I believe that in myself.
And it all comes from
how prepared you are.
He's always doing every single thing,
not like,
I'm going to be lazy today.
Every sing he has to do,
and that's the reason he feels so
fucking prepared and can focus on her
techniques and can focus on
that instead of focus on,
oh,
am I going to gas or did I train hard
enough or fuck all that nonsense shit.
Yeah.
I was listening to someone talk about
that the other day that wish I could
remember who was having this conversation.
It might've been my friend John Dudley,
but he was talking about how when people
aren't prepared for things that it
gives you like another layer of insecurity
on top of the insecurity of doing
something that's difficult
in the first place.
So if you know that you're not like,
maybe you're good at it but you're just
lazy and you didn't really practice and
then you're going to go
and try and do something,
but you know these other people are
practice much harder than you have.
That layer is even if you're a talented
person that's like that has an effect on
your actions and if you've
done everything you can do,
you've dotted all your i's
and crossed all your t's.
If you've done that,
you'll have a different
level of confidence.
You might still lose,
right?
It's a crazy way to make live in
the chips fall where they may,
but at least you'll know that you gave
100% now if you lose and you didn't give
100% you definitely still have.
You always have that in the back
of your head as like a fallback.
Hey,
I know I didn't really give
100% but you could say,
well,
I'm going to get my shit together now,
but the problem is you've already gone
through the experience of not giving 100%
which is very precarious because it could
be a confidence destroyer could fuck
your head up for the rest of your life.
It could change who you are because it's
very difficult for people to overcome
the past like ideas that they have
about themselves from a year ago or five
years ago.
That is not you and you.
You have to,
especially in something as critical
as like fight skills and learning,
learning how to become confident again.
That's not you.
That was you.
Then your better now embrace
the fact that you're better.
Don't dwell on bad moments where you
got flattened or you're fucked up or you
did something stupid or you
got caught in an arm bar,
whatever the fuck it is,
those things they can get in your head
and you can decide you're that person or
you can decide,
no,
I've passed that now I'm
way better because of that.
I'm thankful that happened because that
taught me as super valuable lesson and
without that humiliation and that
defeat or that misstep or you know,
whatever that error was,
I would know who I really am right now.
Yeah.
It's like classic sports psychology stuff
and you can't just read it one to be
like,
okay,
I get that.
You got to fucking just wrap it in
your head wrapped around your head.
And I think,
I truly think in a fist fight.
The number one thing is confidence.
And I know that confidence comes from
training and also helps to have that
fucking rumble.
Johnson power sun,
that might also be a
rumble Johnson,
Cory,
you rely on people,
you rely on it too much.
And that's why I don't necessarily
think he relied on the too much,
but I really think about rumble
is rumble was better than he was,
um,
enthusiastic about fighting.
He was a better fight.
Like he said it,
he was a phenomenal knockout artists.
I mean,
rumble put it to people,
you know,
a spooky way.
He would cry when he knocked out,
glow over to shower and to
share that one upper cut.
Boom.
You've watched that precision
and the power that guy generated.
Damn.
He was scary.
He was scared,
but when bill said,
when he retired,
he said,
hey man.
He goes,
I'm just good at this.
I'm not a fighter.
He was,
I'm an athlete.
He goes,
I'm just good at this.
I don't want to do this anymore.
I could do a lot of other things.
It was like good for you and your
fucking at the top of your game.
Everyone's scared of you and you're like,
man,
I'm good at those.
I mean like it,
I'm going into the weed business.
Fuck yeah.
Yeah.
I mean rumble is a,
he's a special person,
but that kind of thing that he has,
he's got that one touch gift.
I mean for sure.
Technique for sure.
Years of training for sure.
Smart knows how to execute
and close the distance.
There's a lot of excellent
variables on his side,
but there's one thing that he possesses
that most human beings are never going
to get.
No matter how they try.
They're not going to get that power.
He's got that weird power.
There's a few people that just have their,
they got that weird power man,
that fat fast twitch muscle that gases
out quick or the slow twitch muscle like
Nick Diaz that can push
and press the whole time.
It's like,
see Ryan and that always
gas up quick though.
Here's the thing he did in some fights,
but if you watch the Phil Davis fight,
he never gassed out for a second.
That fight.
People forget who like
fucking filled Davis is good.
He's real good and Womble put it to him.
Phil Davis was in survival mode and the
other guy about that survival mode son,
they'll gave it.
Yeah man,
he wasn't,
there was no wrestling
to be done in that fight.
There's defense back to the feet,
keep ducking,
keep ducking because
missiles are coming your way.
Or if he's with like Henri Hooft at that
time was who've helped him that with
that for certain,
I mean,
look,
but I really believe that all those
tough training camps and tough fights and
you know,
those battles that after a while he
just didn't want to do it anymore.
Even if he's that good at it.
He was one comfortable,
stressed out all the time,
always get ready for a fight.
He didn't want to do it anymore.
He's a smart guy.
Yeah.
You know,
I think there's something
admirable about that,
about him saying even though
he's on top of the heap,
you know,
just lost the title.
Right?
Yup.
Decides.
You know what?
Fuck it.
I'm done.
Well,
he got beat twice.
Maybe like you said,
maybe do more like twice in a row.
He,
yeah.
He one who did he beat in between?
No,
he beat a couple people.
I think he beat Glover.
He docked out clover in between.
That's right.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
who else did he,
she was fucking terrifying.
It was tallyman.
But then he tried to make the lens
of 70 he did make like 70 many times.
He used to fight at one 75 on tough
at one 70 at that high level too,
when there's so much on the line,
you get a fight 10 weeks out.
Okay.
Now every single day my thoughts are
filled with what's going to happen in that
fight for 10 fucking weeks and it's
exhausting knowing that I might make this
much money or I might
make double that much.
I can't plan ahead at all.
You've got to go based on
what happened in the fight.
I'm not a big believer in that.
I don't like that.
That's one part of the way people get
paid that I wish wasn't a tradition.
The fight and then when bonus,
I just feel like everybody's trying
to win and then the decisions.
Yeah,
the,
to see if it was one thing,
like if it was a rock solid decision
process where we did it all in a computer
and everyone agreed and
everyone voted online.
Yeah.
Then okay.
Because it might cost you $50,000 if
someone has a terrible idea of whether or
not you want to fight or not and sometimes
sometimes they're close and sometimes
they're subjective and sometimes it's
things that you might be looking for that
might be you might think isn't good
enough to score and maybe you think the
defense is just as important because
even though he took him down,
he didn't do anything and the guy on
the bottom was always working off of his
back or you're a boxer,
I'm a Jujitsu guy.
Like yeah,
look,
there's always those things,
but I think those could be
ironed out with a large,
large enough sample group or a
large enough group of judges.
Like if we add,
why would you cage?
Why those three?
What do we need?
Three,
tell me.
There's not thousands of people listening
to this right now that would make
phenomenal judges shit that,
no MMA,
that understand Jujitsu,
that no kickboxing all together.
I mean there's got to be a fucking shit
ton of amount there that would do an
amazing job if you let them do it online.
Let him watch it online,
let them judge it online,
have a little camera on
them while they do it.
So you know they're
actually watching the fight.
Let them watch it.
Don't just no commentary.
Just to let you know at
the sounds of the impacts,
how about let's get a bunch
of people watching the show.
What would it take to like
push an idea like that?
It's like we just used to Joe Louis
versus Max Schmeling that judge and judge
Walkley and judge Judy's
over and this job,
when we use this stupid old boxing system,
you know that system sucks.
A Fat Dick.
They need to have a gang of people judging
fights because she'd be way more than
three and they should be super
educated in terms of like high level
understanding of
submission holds striking.
They should be able to demonstrate it.
What's more significant?
An elbow to the top of the head or a
leg kick depends on who's throwing the
kick.
Depends on the stone,
the elbow,
what's,
what's better a take down or take down
to lead you to get caught in a triangle
that you eventually survive in.
But you almost get tapped in and out.
Did it not count?
What if a guy gets you really close to
a triangle and he's got you trapped in
there,
you try to slam on,
he tightens it up more and there's a
battle and you're going back and forth and
back and forth and back and
forth and finally you get out.
Do you get more credit
because you took him down?
Then he gets for almost strangling you.
That's super subjective.
Super subjective and different
people would disagree.
They will argue over it.
I've seen really high level referees
and judges argue over what they think is
more important in better.
It's so subjective and it's crazy,
but I think if we had a giant number,
man,
if we had a big number,
if you have a hundred people,
I'm getting crazy idea.
20 experts have a certified expert
panel and you have these people.
You give them access
to the fight for free.
You pay them a certain amount of money,
they get no commentary.
They listened to the fight
play out in real time.
They have the options of tuning into
each corner or individual corners if they
want.
It's easy to arrange.
We have that right now so if we decided
to do that and give that to someone who
calls at home who wants to not just watch
fights but is also an expert and would
love the idea of making 100 bucks
or whatever the fuck they pay.
You have this camera prompt over their
head have have a online contributors and
nice.
Yeah and and maybe you know maybe
have fucking 10 people do it.
Maybe you have 20 people do it,
but it doesn't in this day and age like
why would you not have more analysis
better than that.
It's just not a good idea to throw
three unskilled people that their only
experiences watching
fights and judging them.
Like literally they don't have
any martial arts experience.
That's a common theme.
Like there's,
it's high level.
MMA fights are often,
the decisions are decided by people
that have zero martial arts experience,
which is crazy.
It's like me judging a violin contest.
It really is like,
I don't know a goddamn thing about,
I could get it totally wrong.
I could get it totally wrong that people,
I would go,
oh I love the part we did that.
Like that was a mistake.
You fucking is not supposed
to make that sound.
That's why he should lose.
I'm like all,
I thought that was cool.
Yeah.
That's how it is when a lot
of these people literally
don't have any idea what's
happening.
I have a friend who was a judge who
told me wallow fight was going on.
This is many years ago
while a fight was going on,
this guy was working for a Komora
and this lady who's a judge goes,
what is he doing?
What is he doing?
She says it to him cause she
needs to know cause she's,
she's watching the fight.
She doesn't know if that's a hold.
Like what is that?
Is this,
is this work?
Is this real?
And she's actually judging a fight
and he said I was flabbergasted.
Fuck.
He goes,
she literally didn't
understand what was happening.
She didn't know a Kamora
of like super common,
super common move.
She didn't know it.
Death crazy.
Did you listen to the commentary
at all in sugar spike?
I don't think so.
Oh fuck.
Which fight?
Andre?
He was whining about meats and stuff.
Oh,
in between corners?
No,
it was during the fight.
I was just jabbering that Andre a little
bit just cause I knew that that big
pressure moment he was feeling that I
was just laughing when he missed or just
little things and make fun
of them are a little bit,
cause I know he was thinking
about it and I know that,
do you know him well?
No,
but I could see the pressure
of the buildup of him all week.
He was getting super emotional,
so I knew that little extra push
we'd get him emotional teamwork.
And then after he tweeted,
he's like,
all I could hear is it's fucking corner
talking shit to me the whole time.
And that's all I could like,
wow.
I'm like,
I know at the high high
level it's not going to work,
but I just feel it's another tactic.
Yeah,
right.
I mean maybe it will like who would,
who would it work on?
We'll just say like these guys or these
guys are UFC fighters and their town.
Everyone respects them
and treats them nice.
And then all of a sudden you're in this
place where two guys are talking shit to
you and then you're fighting one and
he's laughing at you in this and they're
like,
oh fuck.
I'm not used to this.
It's just another tactic.
But I know at a certain
level it won't work.
But why not?
Certain level?
It might work a little though.
It's just another.
Yeah.
And I want people just want people
fucking trying to hit sugar hearts and
they're stiff.
So he's waxing them as they come in.
Well,
definitely don't talk
about it on the Internet.
If you want it to have it still happen.
It still happens.
I'm sure.
I'm just saying give it up.
Your strategy son believes in it though.
I trust it.
I believe you believe in it.
You definitely a fast learner man.
You know,
it's uh,
it's interesting how you have a,
a style of moving and throwing kicks
that I would have assumed that you have
like a long background in some sort of
traditional martial arts or karate or
taekwondo or something because
the way you thrown kicks,
I was like the sky like the way,
but I guess that's like a lot of
also your emulation of Connor,
right style.
Yeah,
I was,
I was kind of doing that before,
before I saw Connor just
kinda throwing weird kicks.
I remember being at the lab and
watching videos and trying them,
just teaching myself then.
But as far as my movement
that I played basketball,
football,
soccer and baseball my entire life since
I was four until I was in high school,
I think I was just became a math super
athletic from doing so many different
sports.
And then I added that to fighting and
I don't know.
It works well.
Well,
your length too,
man,
that's a big factor.
That's like a six four guy at one 70.
That's switching stances.
Five ten five 11 five 11 five
10 for one 35 is so crazy.
Yeah,
there's some,
as you walk around,
wait one 51 and put it
in your arms real quick.
Like I fucking long his stretches for
30 for 35 like how hard is it for you to
get down to 35 super easy.
Super easy.
Yeah.
What do you think about this recent move?
A Dana white has just said that he's
going to eliminate the early weight cuts.
Is that really?
I hope that that would be the worst thing.
That's so stupid.
And you said too many people are missing
the weight and they're trying to gain
the system and they're trying to cut more
because they know that have more time
to recover.
Yeah,
I would a huge,
I love the,
the night.
It's easy.
Thank you.
Fucking still know what time Wayne's are.
Do you think it's possible that they
could ever eliminate weight cutting
entirely?
I hope so.
I would love that.
I don't know.
I just,
yeah,
find out what your actual
weight is and fight it.
That,
I mean if you're too muscular,
loose weight,
if you're too fat,
there's some fat,
but find out what weight
you're at and just,
I think that's an unnecessary danger.
That's the Nice thing about Shaun.
He's not a huge one 35 or so weeks.
We don't have to eat to get huge like
George said or eat to really dial it down.
We can eat to where he just performs the
best and just stay there and then maybe
have to cut eight pounds,
eat normal the whole week,
drink normal the whole week and
then go in there feeling 100% yeah,
it's just,
it's an unnecessary aspect.
And I think one of the things that would
be a solution is give guys more options
of what weight to actually fight at when
there's these big giant gaps in between
weight classes.
It forces people in a lot
of ways to cut weight.
Cause like maybe they're just too small
for one 85 but they can make one 70 so
fuck it.
I'll just make one 70 because I
know how big x guy is or why guys.
Cause you know some of those 85 man,
you're around them.
You're like Ho Lee Shit.
Fuck.
This is a fucking heavyweight.
Hale.
Geez Hales big fella.
There's a lot of them.
Luke Rockhold is a big hazy fella.
He's big,
he's big and strong as fuck.
And you know he weighs one 85 so if
you're in that guy's way class like good
luck.
Fuck face.
How about Yo Al Romero?
Yo and row is one 85 are
you fucking kidding me dude?
He's one of the most impressive physical
specimens I've ever been in front of.
I mean phenomenal wrestler,
talented fighter,
all of the above.
But just his physique.
Like he just looks like a superhero.
He doesn't look like a real person.
Have you been around him in
real life to flex your traps?
You look like Yo el a little bit.
Okay,
well dude,
he was here in that shirt in that seat
and he was wearing this tight shirt with
like a gold cross and shit and you know
it's skin tight and you look at it and
be like,
well an in between fights and he's not
trying to make one 85 he's well over 200
pounds.
He's fucking jacket.
He's got that Super Cuban DNA son theory.
I wonder what DC is going to way
going into fight with Steve Bay
jacked Yo Romero is jack
could not be a nicer guy.
Be a nicer,
that's cool.
He was,
he's beautiful.
He's like that might be funny
and friendly and he's a sweet,
sweet guy.
He's laughing all the time.
He's so happy to not be in Cuba.
And when he talks you about Cuba,
like he's explaining,
you know like he can go back to Cuba.
He's one of the few guys that can go
back to Cuba and then leave and come back
to the United States.
Yeah,
yeah.
It says it's crazy.
He says,
you got to keep your mouth shut
and move around and you know,
watch what you say and don't piss anybody
off cause they all want to leave and
they can't leave and you can leave and
come back and leave and come back for
raising.
It's weird like usually someone
who's super fucking Badass,
they're always really nice.
He's so nice.
Soldier of God does that as t shirt.
I love you.
Oh,
oh we need an account and ordered me that.
Then I'll take that in the large please.
That's awesome.
That's a dope one.
Yeah.
They're coming out with funny shit.
You know this is yours,
right?
Yeah,
it's sold out the first like couple of
hours on the rebbe on a couple different
websites.
They just got it back in stock.
I would come on,
sorry bar.
Come on.
So it was beautiful.
They had a marijuana leaf behind
that at first and it was so sweet.
They had to get rid of the marijuana.
Yeah,
that's it.
I I I imagine they need to let it go
in this day and age you let it go.
It was a rest.
They weren't willing to think of how many
people told you not promote marijuana
at the UFC will not
ever sign you back then?
Maybe,
but not anymore.
Like couple of years ago,
Sean is like the first
day be open about it.
Um,
is that True Nick Diaz?
Come on.
So I guess that's true.
Um,
Nick Diaz has always been a black hawk.
Yeah,
that's true.
Open as fuck.
People are open about weed.
It's more behind the scenes.
Well Dana doesn't give a fuck.
The only thing that they care about
is commissions and people you know,
failing the test,
which they think it's
stupid in the first place,
then it doesn't give a fuck.
People smoke weed.
If there were like there,
he's right.
He'd rather have him smoke weed.
I'm sure.
Especially now that it's legal then drink.
But 10 years ago,
what was he like five years ago?
It's all about the commissions.
He's a promoter.
He's not a guy who interferes
with people's Personal
Pottsville cause he doesn't
like it.
Same moral in my company we're gonna.
Yeah,
none of that.
He just,
his opinion is based entirely on
the fact you're going to get tested.
So if you're smoking pot,
you can't stop and you're six weeks out
and you know you fucking pass that limit
because there used to be pleased to be
looking for a very small amount and you
would,
you would need a good solid four
to six weeks to flush your system.
And some guys would j they push it,
they get into three,
they get into three weeks and just drink
a lot of fucking water and apple cider
vinegar and tried to clean their system
out and sometimes it would work and
sometimes you would deal with a really
sophisticated commission and they would
catch you.
Pat Heeley,
Jim Miller when pat one
both bonuses that night,
130 gs.
That's right.
Tested positive for pot,
got a hundred case bonus away and the
Wynn and his wind bone and is when,
I mean look,
do you think the pod helped him win?
Get the fuck Outta here.
Shit.
It's crazy.
And it was just a little amount.
He pushed it,
you know,
I mean,
and pat is a guy that fights
like a fucking savage,
so you know,
he trains like that too.
So it's all just fucking crying,
going and smashing.
And so he's probably sore all the time,
man.
Yeah.
You know,
if you're,
if you fight that fucking wrestler,
uh,
the top games,
smash them up style like he does.
Yup.
And that grit style,
he's got that put it to you.
Just keep that pressure
on youtube break style.
Those guys get sore as fuck,
man.
They need some pot.
Calm him down for sure.
We're going to look back on it someday.
It's going to be ridiculous.
We're going to look back on the fact
that pot was illegal when we're kids,
we're going to be like,
how in the fuck is that possible?
Some people take it to
their graves though.
We'd the day my mom,
they just don't get it.
It's,
it's not their fault.
here's the thing,
weeds the devil for some people,
but alcohol's the devil for some people,
you know,
gambling's the devil for some
people jerking off as the devil.
For some people.
There's people that get,
they get caught up in all kinds of
shit because people are fucked up.
We're weird,
you know,
but it's not,
the pot.
Pot is not the problem.
You throwing out the
baby with the bath water.
This shit is good for people.
It helps you.
It makes you think more.
It opens your eyes to weird things.
It makes you,
it makes you nicer to people.
Yeah,
it really does.
Oh,
for sure.
Yeah,
Right.
Makes you just get my
mom to take one puff,
a little puff.
Just still the big do it.
What about edibles?
No,
no way.
Yes.
One of the camp six,
seven,
eight weeks out.
I pretty much,
I've,
I've only vaporized and use edibles and
then once I start getting to that three,
four weeks,
I'm only do edibles
right here.
We don't have any jam here.
I got to get you this Jambo spray.
Oh,
change your life.
The spray.
Oh yeah,
but be careful.
I have this liquid.
It's the liquid you
pour under your tongue.
That's right.
Yeah.
Be careful.
That's like acid.
I ain't going people with those.
Dabbers all those wacky people
with the wax too heavy for me.
Go Fuck yourself folks.
Be going too far.
They're out.
They're out in the land of no.
Those like,
that's like the marijuana equivalent
of those people that take that Krokodil
drug.
You know those people that take that shit,
that rots.
You ever seen that Krokodil with some
drug that was in fact affecting a lot of
people apparently.
And um,
was it eastern bloc states?
Russia?
I think it was Russia,
but it rots your skin away to the
point where your bones exposed.
Since people would shoot it right into
the spot where they're bone was exposed.
Like that's how crazy this drug.
If it's so,
it's so powerful and so
crazy and feel so good,
they shoot it right into the rotten meat.
What would their exposed bone,
oh,
this photo's man all over the Internet.
It will freak you out in Colombia,
Colombia.
Uh,
that's where it is.
This one artist.
Okay.
Is there one from Russia?
I feel like there was a
theme about Russian kids that
were shooting Krokodil and
this burnt out warehouse.
It was like,
what the fuck?
Damn.
Fuck Dude.
It's heart pumps and photos,
son.
Don't talk.
Gross us out from a distance.
Look at that.
That's real.
So that lady shooting
that stuff into her arm,
the meat rotted away.
Her bone is exposed.
She can't help it.
Man.
That stuff just starts.
It starts rotting their flesh away
and a lot of people wind up like this,
man,
look at this lady.
Look at her arm.
Who got her forearm?
Krokodil.
Yeah,
look at it.
Ate Away or forum,
man,
there's almost nothing
left of her forearm.
This is a really common thing
that you could find online.
If you want to throw up,
look at that guy's foot.
It just [inaudible].
I don't know,
man.
I'm too scared to ask.
I don't even,
to me that one hand,
click on that here.
Where your cursor's on.
Click on that.
Oh Jesus.
Look at this.
Look at this person.
Squirting it into their leg toward God.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my God.
It's eaten that person's ass.
All right,
that's enough.
Thank you for not showing these online.
People just get so fucking damaged.
What?
What is that drug that makes it like
imagine itch that's so hard to not scratch
that you'll,
you're willing to shoot the drugs.
She's into the hole where the bone is.
Fuck,
people are fucked up,
man.
People are fucked up and
a lot of it's this weird,
like they were saying in this,
uh,
podcast from zero to three.
You learn more than you'll
ever learn in your whole life.
And we don't even remember that.
Like when people say that,
I go,
maybe you bro.
I really,
I thought pattern like 10
times stronger than heroin.
Three times more toxic.
Jesus.
It's a 10th of the price.
Oh,
that's the problem.
It's a bar.
It's Costco.
Costco drug.
So what were we're saying that you learn
more by the time you're three zero from
zero to three,
then you'll ever learn in your life
taking in more information about like
everything.
Huh?
Just being programmed from that like,
and we don't even remember that.
And that forms maybe a lot of
patterns that are brains now.
Like,
oh,
for sure.
Idea.
Oh,
for sure.
Um,
especially if a kids grow around,
grew up around violence,
violence in the house,
violence in their community.
Uh,
especially even if their mom
was going through violence,
whether in the womb,
that's it,
that has a giant factor in the way you
connect the dots and the way you interact
with people.
I was on a plane once headed to Australia
and Michael Irvin was on the plane
just by random,
you know,
it's a long ass flights,
like 14 hours.
So me and him got to
talk and super good dude,
like real nice guy.
I mean phenomenal football player,
but just like you would
never know it talking to him,
just super,
super down to earth.
But he was talking about um,
work he does with kids,
with um,
kids that and trying to sort of,
uh,
aluminate to people.
What happens to someone who grows up
in a terrible community where they
experience a lot of violence in the
neighborhood or their family experiences,
violence or that the mother does
while the boys in the womb that this
literally their behavior patterns,
thought pattern,
they come out of that,
they come out of the
gate with a faster fuse,
a shorter fuse,
uh,
more,
more inclinations towards violence.
You know,
different hormone rates.
Either their body reacts
to stress differently,
they're quicker to snap,
the quicker to make impulsive,
violent judgments and
beat people up and shit.
Like a lot of the people
that are in these situations,
like what you're dealing with is like a
programming from the time they're in the
womb and it's very difficult to correct.
And then we have to like really not
think about it in terms of like here's a
person who's doing a bad thing and
think about it more in terms of like,
well wait a minute,
why is he so angry?
How did he get like this?
What,
what happened?
Like we can just get out of let it happen
over and over again and keep blaming
people who get it wrong and say,
hey,
everybody figured out because we're
going to keep locking you up or,
or should they look at it and go,
how is this happening?
What is causing people?
Hey look,
Mike grew up on the south side of Chicago.
Everyone in his neighborhood was
getting beat up and shot and you know,
if someone says something to him,
he can't even help.
But he just sucker punches you cause
he's on edge all the fucking time.
Are we supposed to treat him the same way?
We're going to treat Chad who grows up
in the country club and the where's izod
shirts and his,
his parents are both on Xanax and
everybody's cool and the maid raised him.
I'm like,
go get a tree.
No,
they're not the same people.
These are not the same kind of
human beings like some human beings.
They got a shitty deal.
They got a shit deal,
man.
Does she get a shit deal
coming into this planet?
We've got to figure out how to stop those
shit deals from taking place so often
figure out a way to like
make it nicer for people.
Like the worst problems are people that
come out of horrible situations in their
life when they're young and then go on
to do violence and terrible things when
they get older.
Yeah.
If you could just get
to them that early fuck,
look,
everybody calm down,
everybody relax.
Like let's figure out a way to get you
all paths to success and get you to
figure out like coaching and life
coaching and education and counseling and
community and you're wanted and loved
and everyone's together and you have a
stake in this game just
as much as everybody else.
Yeah.
And then it have this kid
with kids when they're young,
you'll develop phenomenal human beings
instead of people that are likely to grow
up and you know,
engage in the kind of patterns
that they saw all their life.
Yeah.
I think like a big bet
going our school system,
like we're not taught
how to use our brains.
We're not taught how to deal with
certain emotions when they arise.
We're just taught math,
science,
all that stuff.
I think the school system,
we need to implement more teaching
us how to meditate and a control,
our thoughts,
our emotions.
Just like Rhonda Patrick says like what
the mom's eating has so much to do with
how that baby's formed and how
healthy it's foreign for sure.
Sure.
Small extent.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's all,
there's so many factors and then,
you know,
there's things
that you're just never gonna be able
to control like where you're born,
like,
who,
who your parents are,
what part of the world do you live on?
And we were all lucky as shit,
even the poorest of us to be here in
America where you could be in a shitty
neighborhood and managed to get out and,
and become,
uh,
at least a financial success is
places where that's just not possible.
You know,
literally how lucky are we that we're not
living in fucking Singapore where they
could just pull you over and just lock
you in a cage for a year because you
liked to smoke plants.
Yeah.
No Shit.
It's fucking insane shit.
Yeah,
we're,
we're all insanely lucky.
I bet it's pretty crazy being a dad.
It's crazy.
I'm bet.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
It's hard to wrap your head
around it until you experience it.
I bet.
Dude,
it is a very,
very rewarding,
but it's also very strange,
very humbling changes your whole
perspective on things you like.
You love these little people in a way
that you didn't even know you could love
and it's,
you just feel different.
You feel different about people.
I look at people now,
men,
women,
everybody.
I look at them like
they used to be a baby.
That started to happen almost
immediately after I had a kid.
Like I never used to
think about it that way.
If I saw some dude and he was fucking
like 70 years old yelling at people,
fuck you,
get off my lawn or whatever,
you know,
I'd be like,
look at that old dickhead.
I'll beat your ass.
I just think he's an old dick
and fuck that little dickhead.
But now I go,
oh,
that was a baby man.
That was a baby that
just went through life.
And then got to the point where it's this,
this old man who just,
you know,
everybody could ride that
fucking mechanical bull for
a second or two and seven
years old and you're like,
get off my line and you just can't wait
to go back inside and drink yourself to
death and you're watching judge Judy.
You know what,
that's,
there's a lot of people like that.
Those people that are out there just in
a room with the fucking walls are yellow
with cigarettes.
Just constantly smoking.
They got a greasy film on all
the windows thrown into Tony's.
Yeah,
they're just ordering pizza and they're
fucking whole house smells like shit.
Those people are alive right now and
they were babies and now they're 80 now
they're 80 years old coffin.
They got a tube in their neck.
Maybe they got a fucking oxygen tank.
They take with them the little
too that goes up their nose.
And how were they raised?
Who were they raised around?
Yeah.
How were they raised?
Did they get a good deal?
They eat.
Yeah.
They get a good,
they get a good deal with around nice
people when they were young or did people
smack him for no reason when they were
a little baby that people drop them on
their head.
What happened to him?
You know,
what kind of education did they get?
What kind of nutrition
did they get growing up?
How well did their brain develop?
God,
you know,
it really does make you want to
just treat everyone nice suit.
It could be us.
That's the thing.
You could be born in uh,
uh,
terrible community in,
you know,
fill the bikes.
Russia,
you could have been born there.
You could've been in some
nightmare crime infested part of Liberia.
You could have been fine.
There could have been you,
you could be in Libya right now.
You could be a little child born in Libya
right now you have no control of your
environment.
And there is basically a failed state
where they're reintroducing slavery,
open markets.
You can watch people,
there's slave trade auctions on youtube.
You could see him in Libya.
Yeah.
Did you ever,
if you've seen it right?
Jemele terrifying.
So Frances and Gyno spoke out about it
after he knocked out Alistair Overeem.
It's one of the things that he wanted to
talk about when he knew he was going to
be fighting for the title.
Basically,
you know,
in his,
he had,
he's not the best at English.
She's still learning it.
But he was like,
you know,
I just want to say fuck slavery like this.
This is crazy that this is happening
today in 2018 they have slavery and Libya.
They ha they were shipped people or
cell phone camera footage of the slave
auction.
It's going on.
Damn,
dude,
that's fucked up.
Yeah,
that could be us.
we can be born there.
You know,
we got lucky.
Everyone got lucky and
some got lucky than others.
But the,
the lack of just,
not just an understanding of that,
but the action,
like the fact that we always think we
have to do all these different things in
other countries.
Uh,
we have to go over there and help
these people out there trade.
Oh,
we have to go over here and
there's a steel embargo.
We need to talk to these people.
Yeah,
yeah.
We were sure we definitely do.
But what,
you know,
we really need to do.
We need to fix up these
fucking poor cities.
Fixed this up.
You had a horrible poverty.
You've got places where you have block
after block with boarded up windows and
you know,
this is exists,
right?
The reservations.
Oh Dude.
Ah,
that's a different world.
They're two different worlds.
It really is.
Yeah.
But it's like that's never
something that's discussed
when people talk about the
problems that this country
faces there they live roughly,
you know,
economic crisis and they use words like,
um,
you know,
welfare and a quality or you know,
uh,
income inequality,
the use these terms.
But at the end of the day,
we don't think about,
no,
it's just like people that are fucked,
they're fucked.
Like their,
their situation is fucked.
It's not good and they don't get the
same break is someone who lives in a nice
neighborhood in Columbus,
Ohio.
They're not getting the same break.
It's a different situation.
And until you fix that,
you're going to make
criminals and angry people.
And pay people that are
dysfunctional and people that are,
you know,
they're lashing out because
they experienced violence
and no love their entire
life.
You can always get that,
Matt,
and this is what I was
talking about earlier,
that our technology is constantly
and rapidly accelerating,
but our understanding of our interactions
with each other is still fucked up.
It's still clunky and
not well thought through.
And as much as we know about so many
different factors in terms of like how
human beings develop,
we put almost no effort into fixing it.
Well,
what the fuck?
What would help?
They would have to go on an all out
campaign to reinvigorate horrible
neighborhoods.
They would have to fix,
they would have to use government
money to fix these houses and fix these
neighborhoods and make,
make it safer with more police force.
Um,
make community centers where
people can go and be safe,
set it up so they can do activities
there that they would like.
You know,
there's,
there's gotta be ways that you can
invigorate these places and you somehow or
another figure out a way to get
work for a lot of these people.
Give them counseling,
give them,
let,
let people know that.
And I've never really been to school
and they're in their fucking twenties
there's a place we can go,
we can teach you how to write and read.
This is real.
There's a lot of people that are
like this and in the real world,
you know,
we can,
we can fix things if we put
money and time into them.
Like the way they decided,
like they were using Halbert and to go
and rebuild places that we blew up in
Iraq.
Like that's what they do.
They go and re fix stuff that we fucking,
they build,
they build shit that we fuck up.
You know,
they go over and then they put power
plants and do all kinds of other shit over
there.
But they had to get these giant
contracts to go over there and do that.
Okay.
Well we definitely blew things up
so we should definitely fix it.
But shouldn't we fix Chicago too?
What are you going to gang
violence constantly in Chicago.
Death rate in Chicago is crazy.
Right?
Or Detroit or you know,
fill in the blank,
whatever bad neighborhood it's
experiencing some sort of a drug conflict.
Reservations.
Yeah.
And then how about the fact collectively
we all need to look at the fact that
there's Mexico's right next to us and the
only reason why they have such violent
crimes,
cause we lack drugs and we
keep those drugs illegal.
So bad guy sell drugs.
Like this is fucking stupid shit ever.
It's like you don't,
you know it.
Everybody knows it.
This isn't,
I'm not a smart guy.
Like if I know it,
I'm not,
I'm no genius.
If I know the solution.
You don't think the people in the
highest levels of government know the
solution.
But Dude,
you're a lot smarter than you think
because think of the people you talk to
everyday,
deep conversations as you guys are a
lot of knowledge that people have never.
Yeah.
But see that's the difference between
knowledge that you just sort of remember
things that people have told you,
which I got some of that and
actually have an an education in it.
That's the difference.
Like if people ask me about martial arts,
I can understand almost everything you
want to talk about with martial arts,
with the exception of some
judo and some wrestling,
you know,
some judo and some wrestling.
I would want to talk to an expert in
what makes sure that I got my positions,
my,
my understanding of what
the best thing to do.
But everything else I'm going to
sacred in Michael Poland said though,
how long on sleep,
how long do doctors get?
Like how long is their
courses on sleep one course.
How long exactly listened to them
or do you listen to your podcast?
Yeah,
but I don't listen to them
when it comes to sleep.
I listen to a guy like Matthew
Walker who's asleep expert.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
There are those.
He's a real,
he's a real sleep expert so he's the
guy that I should listen to but just
because I can pair it what
he says don't get confused.
Like I'm not smart.
I just remember shit.
But that's in a way,
that's smart dude.
If you could see how my fucking
brain actually functions,
how I write material and why I need to
constantly keep moving and you'd be like,
oh,
you're just crazy.
You're not smart.
You just a crazy nice person.
That's what it is.
Open minded to definitely open minded.
I think I need to be,
and I think we all need to be,
I think it's one of our
main problems as people,
and I've been absolutely
guilty of this in the past,
is that we cling to an idea
as if it's our identity.
I'll give it as it,
if it defines us instead of looking like,
am I right?
I might not be right.
Like there's a lot of power in saying,
damn,
I'm wrong.
There's a lot of power in that.
There really is and we
need to recognize that.
We need to recognize like there's power
in saying you're sorry this power and
like,
dude,
I've,
I definitely fucked up.
It was,
I was in the wrong 100%.
I just,
I don't know what I did.
I'm sorry.
You know it,
there's,
there's power in that.
He's Poe.
I feel bad about it.
There's power in saying,
you know,
I thought this was correct and it wasn't.
I really feel stupid.
Uh,
sorry.
Argued.
That's so hard.
I really thought I was right.
I'm fucking idiot.
You gotta be willing to do that if
people were less willing to do that.
It's like there's some people,
they say something and they stick with
it and then they'll fucking die on that
hill.
Right?
Like this is why it was so weird that
Donald Trump was trying to say that the
eagles never stood for the Superbowl.
There were the kneeling and the,
you know,
enough of them didn't want to come.
So I'm canceling this party uninvited him.
That's crazy.
And that's why it's crazy.
It's crazy because of the way we,
we really,
in our heart of hearts and understand
how people are capable of communicating
with each other.
Yeah.
It's pretty cool.
We're capable of being
way better than this.
We just clumsy or just stumbling into
each other and head butting each other and
shit like a mosh pit and he goes,
you're just fighting each other.
There's a lot of that,
man.
It's a lot of everybody,
including me,
I've done it to everybody
wanting their side to be right.
Oh yeah.
Just get so stupid with it.
That's why it's hard to like wander
out up out of your group of friends.
Fuck yeah.
He got like,
Fuck Eh.
Try to trust people.
Right.
Try to find people that aren't
like secretly hoping you fail.
Yeah.
A lot of that,
those people are exhausted.
Similar mindset.
It's constantly sharing different
articles you find in that,
I don't know,
pretty lucky and being
honest about what you know.
You know,
don't pretend to know more than you know.
going to be aware of what you know.
Like someone like you.
Like I could listen to an expert,
nutritionists,
they kind of overweight.
It doesn't look good.
Or someone like you who's
not an expert nutritionist,
but look at your body.
You have a lot of fucking
knowledge that you learned.
Yeah,
but definitely don't listen to me.
Only listened to if I can pair it somebody
else's shit or tell you to go listen
to their shit because I get things wrong.
I,
I don't,
I'm not educated in the
mechanisms of nutrient absorption.
So there's like things that if
you take it with certain things,
it's not good for you.
Nutritionist will know all that stuff.
I'm not,
the person knows.
I know some things like
don't have saturated fat with
refined carbohydrates and
sugar.
It's not a good combination.
Especially if you have certain genes.
I know a bunch of shit.
I know what you're supposed to
eat and not supposed to eat.
But some nutritionists though,
even some like at the EOC Pie,
they'll be like,
oh well not this one.
But a certain nutritionist
went to school for it,
got all their degrees and are like,
yeah,
you can have Mac and cheese for lunch.
And then we'll have like a some
vans waffles to get you started.
It's like,
oh well they must have got some 1990s
education that I'm saying like how much
are those are 1990s educations.
If they don't keep up,
man,
it can be bad.
Right?
Like those food chains from the fucking
eighties and those Dr Seuss books,
you ever see that shit?
It was all like cereal and rice and
grain at the bottom must get a better,
have a lot of that and then and then
after that it was like meat and there was
eggs and it was a goofy
ass food chain man.
Damn.
That's what people thought.
The Food Pyramid,
the bottom of it should
be grains and breads,
which are fine as long as you
don't have too much of it.
That should be a moderation
thing depending on your goals,
right?
Like yeah,
but the thing about the nutrition world,
the real thing,
it is so complex and so it's so involved
that you really need to talk to an
actual expert.
Like if I have issues,
I have questions about things.
My number one go to his doctor.
Rhonda Patrick.
Yeah,
number one.
Cause she's,
she's 100% scientific with all of her.
There's no shenanigans.
When she has an idea about something,
it's based on study.
She can cite those studies
to you literally at the
drop of a hat and she didn't
tell you what the,
what's what's going on.
Like what,
why is this good with that
and why does this help that?
Why is this hurt that like
she's the go to person for me.
She said she's a wizard,
you know,
she's so fucking smart.
So like I could ask something like that,
but I'm not,
I'm absolutely not a nutrition expert.
I know what I've been able to do
that works pretty good for me.
And I've got some loose leaf fucking
duct taped together knowledge,
but they're the real people out there
like Rhonda Patrick or Rob Wolf for Chris
crush or Ben Greenfield like
I'd bet in here weeks ago,
dude,
he's a wizard.
Listen that three times.
What are your probably a purple
or brown belt and nutrition then?
No,
I think I'm a blue belt.
no,
no.
I'm being honest.
50 years old.
And Jack did.
Just crazy.
I told you I'm a crazy person.
I work out a lot.
I take TRT.
Yes.
All those things help.
Yeah.
But,
um,
the,
the real experts,
man,
they're,
their knowledge is constantly growing.
This is the thing about Rhonda that's
so fantastic is she's on top of all of
these peer reviewed papers and new studies
and all these things that are going
on and things that are in the process of
going on because she's in this loop of
clinical,
she's a clinical researcher,
so she's in this loop of all these
wizards and she does her own podcast.
So she's like,
she's constantly up on
everything that's going on.
So she'll send you things about
new data and she's always like,
every time I have her in here,
it's three hours where I
might talk like five times.
Like I might go.
So why does that do that?
That's a good question.
And she's not even looking at notes,
man.
Like she's,
and we get to learn from it at
a young age and apply it dude.
Like,
so who's to say we're not
fighting healthily at 40?
If we monitor injuries and
monitor our sparring and all that,
like,
well the thing is going
to be brain health.
That's the real problem.
The real like cat Ghana was here.
Do you guys see that or listen
to them to see that one yet?
She had a significant brain injury
apparently from Amanda Nunez.
Amanda Nunez through some boulders,
boulders,
they long boulders,
she hurts people.
She's a fucking killer.
That,
and uh,
she was concussed so badly in that fight
that if fucked up or hormone levels,
she became hypo thyroid from
that fight and continues to be.
So to this day,
she gained 25 pounds.
She said there were 20,
25 pounds somewhere in the neighborhood,
somewhere between 20 and 25 pounds.
Could not shake it off.
She goes,
I was,
I was eating like 400 calories a day
and my body would not let go of this
weight.
And then she found out she
was hyperthyroid and she
had all sorts of problems
with her cognition,
with their memory,
with her.
Um,
she couldn't see when she was sparring,
she wasn't seeing things anymore.
She wasn't seeing reads,
you know,
she wasn't like she fainted,
she fainted someone she couldn't see their
reaction she see was just charging at
them full blast.
She's like,
I had no sense of what I was doing.
So she started getting this
crazy magnetic therapy.
They do this thing on Instagram.
Yeah.
You saw it on her Instagram.
And it really helped her 100% brought
her back and she said they'd been able to
do that with soldiers and all these,
they re ignite all these air and they
can target specific areas of your brain
where you're having a hard
time functioning correctly.
Wow,
that's bad.
Yeah.
So she got all of her pallets
back over issues and you know,
she says she feels 100% or close to it,
but that,
that kind of shit,
it gives me hope.
Right?
Like if they can,
well that's one sort of
therapy that they can do.
Maybe there'll be more in the future.
There's a lot of hope and like all this
pioneering stem cell shit and exosomes
and all these different things that
they're working on to try to regenerate
neuro tissue pool.
Really?
Yeah.
Who knows?
I mean,
we're in a,
you know,
amazing,
amazing times,
but again,
this is just technologically
and medically.
Still.
Culturally we're goofy as fuck.
Yeah.
Technologically and medically.
Like fuck you guys.
See that they're going to take
away the bikini's and Miss America.
I saw,
I saw that.
I was like,
come on son Tan.
It's hilarious.
Listen,
they're going to make it a contest.
They're going to not going to
judge them on their looks anymore.
They're going to make it a contest.
They're not going to
judge them on their looks.
Nope.
They're not judging them on
their appearance anymore.
Holy.
Do a different thing.
This is just do a different thing.
Yeah,
but I guess they want
the name Miss America,
but then how does Miss America
Miss America go to Miss Universe?
Is that how it works?
You don't know.
You know he's got all of
them on the saved safety.
Wasn't that what the one where
Steve Harvey's had the wrong person.
He felt that was that Miss
America or Miss Universe,
this universal bloody damn dude,
that would suck.
Toad suck.
It's just a crazy thing,
man.
To have a a beauty contest.
Imagine if they had them for men.
I mean they caught bodybuilding
contest or bodybuilding contest.
That's a different thing.
But imagine if they had just a gorgeous
man competition and the guys just walk
out and they would,
you know,
to ask them questions.
So Pale road head,
we've got to get a redhead in
their showboaty and Boosie all day.
I don't even care about myself.
They're like
crazy shit.
Just like those women,
you know,
everybody's just trying
to say the right thing,
hoping that they get picked.
That's fucking fun.
That's a weird thing,
right?
That this super weird.
It's not something that anybody's
clamoring for quality on.
I'll tell you that like no
one's asking for Mr. Mann,
Mr Handsome,
all America man to university.
Yet
Mr America is only like a bodybuilder.
Mr universes bodybuilder,
this Dorian Yates mother Fucker,
right.
You know that's Lee Haney.
That's mister universe.
Mr Olympia,
right?
Mr Olympia is the top of the heap.
Who's the one with the dreads?
The spiraling dreads.
Which one is the body belt?
Mister universe.
Oh yeah,
that dude.
Oh,
that dude was on fear factor.
Kelly.
Yeah.
Kelly muscle.
Kai Greene.
Oh,
right,
right.
Yeah.
There's some big ass dudes out there.
There's some big fucking dude's out there.
Seriously,
but
what does that look?
It is,
but that's ridiculous.
You have to look at it
waking up and not look at it.
Look at his,
but make it bigger,
Jamie.
Dude.
And He'd get tagged.
Yet the fuck Outta here.
How was that?
A human's ass.
And you hear how GSP,
how messed up he got for
eating all that like,
man,
these guys insides I guess
their lifespans not long.
Right?
That guy must have a
dick like a rhino horn.
We're just a little pecker
head size of these fuckers.
That is just what,
okay.
Now here's the real question.
Here's my question.
I guess maybe I'm ignorant,
but how the fuck could
you tell who's better?
No Shit.
How do you tell they're both.
They're both ridiculous.
Like,
what are you looking for?
Even even on each side.
Right?
How weird is that?
Yeah,
because like at the top level,
when you,
when you watch like a Mr
Olympia or something like
that and you see eight dudes
stand onstage flex and do you,
is one of them stand out to you at all?
Yeah,
they all look super jacked.
Luckily with those two,
those legs,
weird life to live wouldn't it?
Those legs are preposterous.
Those are preposterous thighs.
That shit doesn't make any sense.
I mean look at your legs.
God,
that's Ronnie Mother Fucker Coleman.
Ronnie Coleman in his day.
What would you be?
Beer tactic if you had to
fight that guy in a fist fight.
Hang on or stay away or stay away.
Hang on.
We got get back going to work.
You make them work.
Get two minutes left.
Two minutes.
Keep fighting for under hook.
Stay low.
Yeah.
That guy's
got about 45 seconds and I'm seriously,
I mean it might fuck you up
and throw you through a wall.
No,
I didn't get on his back.
Click.
Yeah.
Well getting on the back.
The problem with that is he will be able
to stand up and he's gonna throw his
body backwards and try to land on you.
It hurt.
Yeah.
You gotta be careful with the whole
ticket guys back when he's still got some
juice in particular,
right?
Yeah.
Street taking someone's back.
All those dudes.
I mean it can be done.
Especially if they've
got some juice in there.
There's still,
they still have strength.
It just run out of air.
It can have that one big explosion.
He's a giant dude though.
He might be so big if
you did get ahold of him.
He likes to just throw you
just spill,
throw you on top of a car till,
I mean how much those guys lift?
Holy Shit.
No Shit.
How much did the owner of that 700 squats?
That's probably just 700 800
x 600 for 20 or some shit.
Right?
A weird lifestyle.
Getting fucking just get jacked everyday.
Skipjack baby.
Yeah,
I can eat all day.
That's a,
that's a,
that's a sport though.
You kind of like get out of it what
you put in like fighting's not always.
You don't get out what you put in.
Always really put in to log in the
left cheek and the right cheek's.
Whoo.
That's a sport where you have to do it.
It's like one of the only sports.
Well,
we just all understand you have to do it.
How do,
how do you not do it?
All right.
Yeah.
Am I right?
I mean at that level,
for sure.
They're all working hard,
but for sure the tickets,
steroids for 95 four 95 Jesus Christ,
Jesus Christ,
Kai Greene,
holy.
That's up.
How powerful human being and that
ain't shit and he's doing it for Reps.
He's doing it for Reps.
Ooh,
that's a strong fucking,
she went to ban 725 and that kind of
strength is that kind of strengths,
Gary,
but it's nothing compared to
that like strong man type shit.
Do you see that Magnuson Guide
that a Magnus Carlsen Dude,
the dude who was a on the game of Thrones,
what's his name?
Is Carson Gone Magnussen
or something like that?
With mountain the Mountain Gregor.
The mountain click icon
or as fucking hamlet.
Yeah.
He seen him slap around.
That was funny.
That guy.
Just one.
What'd you say?
Jamie said his character's name.
I can't say this.
Oh,
what's his real name?
Ooh.
How do you say that?
I'm Greg.
What do you,
how do you say that name
for Julius Bjornsen.
Bjorn son.
He's six foot nine half Thor.
He's six foot nine
is so fucking huge.
Dude.
That guy is so ridiculously huge.
Look at the size of this fucker.
I bet he has to hire dudes to just
to cock block forum.
Just around them all the time going no,
no more.
No more.
Mr Bjorn son must rest.
Mr [inaudible] has no mark comma.
He could decide to this motherfucker.
Let me size this motherfucker.
He'd had nod dead lifts.
A thousand pounds
TV.
A thousand pounds,
Bro.
That's a half a car.
It's a big boy.
What the fuck?
Yeah.
Giant human.
That one dude got into
MMA and is still fighting.
Yeah.
What the fuck is his name?
He fought one of the Gracies.
Who did he fought?
Igor Gracie.
Put Your House key.
Pooja Naski.
Yeah,
keep fighting for,
he's just rushing.
Promotion is this promotion
or Russian promotion?
Maybe he's,
he's slimming down like quite a bit.
It's very interesting.
He's still fighting to him.
Yeah.
I mean if you look at,
um,
yeah,
look at how he used to be up on top.
See Jamie,
those two on the shorts.
Keep going right there.
Yeah,
that's what he used to look like
versus what he looks like now.
He used to be super duper duper Jack,
but he's still fucking snake.
Stupid strong.
Just oop.
It's strong meeting.
But he had to lean up man,
because he was a,
he just couldn't fight like that.
He fought Tim Kennedy,
Bro.
I mean,
I'm,
I'm sorry.
Um,
fuck Tim.
Sylvia.
That's right.
He fought Tim.
Sylvia.
God,
why did I have that escape me?
I was thinking maniac and I couldn't
come up with these last name,
but Tim Silvia beat the shit out of him.
Oh,
I bet.
Well,
he fought Tim Silvia too young.
I mean,
he,
he just thought because
he was big and strong,
he would be able to see if you can
find the Paj Nowicki Tim Silvia fight.
Timmy.
Timmy is a fucking worldclass.
UFC heavyweight is no video,
which say what's it trying
to get directed it to Sylvia,
not Sylvia.
Oh
Damn.
Slimming down and he's like,
fuck,
just go to videos.
Is it habit?
Yeah.
Fair.
It is fair.
It is.
But uh,
Tim just wore his ass out and
Tim was heavy in that fight too.
They just more I'm out and
just kept beating them up.
Tim's giant man.
He's a big motherfucker,
but it's just,
he's just way too skillful,
like put nasty.
He was crazy.
He tried to just beat
on him with his power,
but good luck with all that.
And Tim just kept wearing on them
and need them and fucking him up.
I'm Tim was like super relaxed pace
himself and got him in there and pop,
pop,
not throwing with everything.
He's got to stay in on him.
Real pro.
I mean whoever made this fight is a real
fucking like a real sinister person.
Crazy mismatch.
But I guess puts you in the house.
He wanted it,
man.
That's the what?
A stud.
That guy is.
Damn.
That's cool.
He's a stud.
I mean he really believed in himself.
He feels like he's got that kind of power.
He could kill anybody.
Just smash them.
But it didn't work with Tim.
Yeah.
Tim just eventually started wearing on.
I'm allowed to do cheer when Randy
hit Tim with that overhand right.
That was crazy.
I didn't expect her a couple of seconds.
Yeah,
he threw an inside leg
kick and an overhand right.
And Tim was,
he was out on his feet.
Like Tim said.
He was talking about it at one point in
time in the future and he said that he
forgot what round it was like there.
He was like a,
it's only the third round,
right?
Like Tim is the last round.
He's like,
what?
Like you forgot around.
Yeah.
Like he,
he probably was out on
his feet the whole fight.
I mean,
think about that.
That shot.
Yeah,
he gets caught right on the jaw.
That's nuts.
Seven seconds down.
Look at this inside leg kick hammer.
And it's perfectly placed and you know,
Tim and him were friends and Tim was
really having a hard time believing that
Randy wanted to fight him because
Randy had stated his house.
They stayed together for a while
and been friends and he was off.
Maybe he didn't stay at his house.
I might've made that up.
He keeps it good.
But they were friends.
I know they were good friends and so
Tim was kind of blown away that Randy
wanted to fight him.
But Randy didn't give a fuck.
Robert Falls told me he'd never saw
Randy lives around in the gym ever.
It's an animal dude.
I was there for Randy's debut
fought two times at night.
Oh yeah.
He fought two times that night.
He strangled to people,
smashed him.
And he was basically a wrestler who knew
a few submission hold two had dumped
some boxing in the army,
you know,
and nobody,
uh,
nobody knew anything back then.
It started at 30 something,
right?
Yup.
I think he was like 34
or 35 for his UFC debut.
That's sweet.
Yeah.
And then when he fought v toward,
that's,
that was a really important fight in MMA
or really important fight because v Tor
was like 240 plus pounds.
Then he was a jug.
Same who was jogging tick.
And He,
uh,
had this huge neck,
his neck started in the
middle of his forehead.
He was just so huge and they had wrote,
written for is like strengths.
It's had no known weaknesses.
Like this is how much
of a a monster Vito was.
He's just light and everybody on fire.
But he kept getting bigger
and bigger and bigger.
He kept getting thicker and bigger.
And I think one of the
reasons was Mark Coleman,
I think everybody back then
was scared of Mark Coleman.
Everybody was like fuck.
Cause Coleman was to 65 and full game.
He was always like
between two 55 and to 60,
somewhere in that range.
But so jacked and mark was
a fucking serious wrestler
and he would take you down
and he was going to get on top of
you and he was going to deliver pain.
He was smashing people with headbutts,
no gloves.
And this is the Mark Coleman error and
this is the era where v tour is coming
up.
So [inaudible] gets to
like 240 pounds at fights.
Randy and Randy survives.
The opening barrage really doesn't even
get hit with much and just starts to
slowly chip away at detour until
he gets him up against cage.
Beats him up and get some down and
smashes him and everybody was in shock.
Everybody was like,
what?
How did he lose?
How's it possible and how
did he lose like this?
It was a really important fight in MMA
because it was a fight where you have a
narrative that you think is playing
out and then a lesson gets taught to
everybody like,
no,
you,
you got too big.
This is all muscle that you don't need.
It doesn't help you.
You get tired.
You need to have better endurance.
This is not the way you,
you know,
you fight against a guy who can survive
and we didn't know that yet because
nobody knew that there was
going to be people who survived.
Yeah.
Nobody knew this.
We going to be people
with submission defense.
When people are caught and submissions,
they tapped it'll,
how often did anybody get it
out of anything back then?
Like we know one,
he knew the progression
that it was going to take.
We learned in that Randy
fight that there's,
there's a certain level of winner.
There's guys that just,
they're fucking mental animals.
They just know how to win.
They know how to break people
and you get to see that in Randy.
Man.
It's sweet.
It's crazy.
Like,
and then everyone thought all the
Machida era and there's really,
that was me,
I said,
but the smarter we get,
the real,
there's no going to be an error.
But then you wonder what John Jones,
well,
there's a John Jones air right now.
I mean,
this is the John Jones era.
No question about it.
If you look at the
actual results in fights,
I don't care what they
say about anything else.
This is what people are gonna remember.
When you go back and look at
this era of light heavyweights,
you think about Jon Jones.
It's just like when Muhammad
Ali was in his prime,
people thought about Ali when sugar ray
Leonard was a welterweight champion.
People thought about sugar.
Ray,
you got to think about Jon Jones.
It's definitely the Jon Jones era,
but it's just an error of so
much turmoil and you know,
you want to talk about a guy who had
more potential than probably anybody I've
ever seen fight and anybody.
Yeah,
and John Does the same kind of shit
that you were telling me that you do.
He just makes things
up while he's in there.
Just sees things and goes with it.
Like that thing that he did with
glow over that over hook or yanked,
I shoulder's fucked of a shoulder.
Gracie luck.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't know if he ever did
that in the past before,
but it didn't look like it looked like
you probably just saw it right there and
so let me just yank on this
fuck up is fuck up his shoulder.
John would do crazy shit.
Spinning elbows and all that.
I mean,
he's just,
he knows how to be loose in there and
knows that he knows how to do things.
I wonder.
Steep Age,
John Mackey,
if you're seeing that,
I can't believe we're
going to see Steve Bay.
DC can't believe it either.
I can't believe it.
The live raising more jack for
that flight than any Brian or take,
correct.
Oh,
that's right.
That's the Vegas card.
That is a crazy fight.
Who Wins?
Steve Bay and DC is very interesting
because the last time that we saw steep a
in like a fight with a really
high level wrestler was who?
Who was that?
Who was the last fight where Steve Bay
fought someone who really knew how to
wrestle?
Who's it been?
I'm trying to think.
Well,
he's fought tough guys.
He fought.
Mark Hon.
If our junior,
it was much more of a boxer briefs.
Shoot.
Yeah.
Fabricio didn't mean
mean free per receive.
Your attack coming in.
So who is like the toughest
wrestler he fought?
If you go back a little bit further,
let's see,
really Nelson Roy Nelson
didn't really keys.
I mean Roy Nelson,
let's be honest.
Roy Nelson could fight middleweight,
right?
Yeah.
He's just an animal.
If he wanted to lose that gut,
how much would he lose?
Holy smokes,
dude.
He's probably walking
around about two 50 right.
But that giant crazy belly.
My height,
which is part of his trademark.
Right.
But if he decided to cut weight and just
go on some crazy diet and cut out all
the bullshit and drain all the fat,
what do you think he would way?
I think you make one 85 easily.
One eight,
five dude.
Easily.
Right?
That's crazy.
Whoa man.
The thing is like Steve Bay's a wrestler,
he's knows what he needs to do and like,
yeah,
going to find out,
man,
he is a wrestler for sure,
but he's not the same caliber of
wrestler that Daniel Cormier is.
But Daniel Cormier is a legit light
heavyweight who has fought successfully at
heavyweight and never lost it.
Heavyweight.
Yep.
So it makes it real
interesting because Daniel,
look,
Daniel,
remember when he fought Josh Barnett and
fucking set up sailing through the air?
Josh is a big fella and that
fucker can grapple today.
He can grapple.
He really knows how to grapple.
Damion,
that's a,
that's a big fucking tall.
I forgot Francis and who?
Derrick Lewis.
Don't blink.
Xtrordinair Holy Shit Dude.
Big dairies one way and fight.
You think so?
I think though,
Jesus,
how the fuck would you anybody
know who's gonna win that fight?
KITSAP pedis.
Paulo Kosta and Uriah Hall.
Oh,
what our card.
This is,
I imagine Paulo coasters of beast.
Imagine the lawsuit chaos
has got going right now.
I know because I heard that they were
going to give him the Habib fight.
Oh my God.
That's terrible.
They were so,
who knows what could have happened?
He upsets Habib.
He gets a fight.
Conor,
who knows to pull out so well Chechen
just shake up the cash register and let's
clean this up.
Mr. Gregory.
Fuck all you have to do a sign right here.
I taught at line.
Well hold on.
Go back to that other card real quick.
We aren't done.
There's still a few in that card.
Ooh.
So key asset versus
pedis is very exciting.
Yeah.
How about this though?
Go [inaudible] back in
the motherfucking mass.
Kahlil Roundtree junior who was obese too.
That's a fucking crazy wild ass fight.
Hooker verse Burns Dude fight there.
It's fun to watch.
He is fun to watch over ton animal.
Yeah.
That's a very,
very good fight.
Very good fight will
hooker is really long,
man.
Real but real physically
strong for that way.
Class to man.
Not just long but fuck man.
And he believes in those knees.
Doesn't
fuck with that guy.
Jim Miller,
who is the other one?
Ross Pearson.
Pearson that and he was so nasty.
Nasty.
Very nasty.
Yeah.
That's a great card man.
Man.
Rafael has sunset sail versus rob font.
That's a great fight too.
That's a sleeper too.
There's some good strikers on that.
[inaudible] was the last guy to beat
TJ before Dominick Cruz beat him.
What?
Did he beat him or was
it like a split decision?
You look at the record and you're like,
Holy Shit,
I feel like a sun south made,
I think it was maybe wrong.
Tj Dillashaw then the unanimous
decision loss says so I'm wrong.
Beat Marlen.
No,
no,
no.
That's UFC 200 they fought before that.
They fought before.
Yeah.
He beat him.
Halfway all suns out.
Brian Caraway,
Tj silicide.
Three dots.
Split decision.
So he want,
yeah,
that's what it was.
So he wants to put decision way back in
2013 and then Tj beat him in 2017 is I
would,
it was 16 TJ.
Well it's Tj just got a lot better.
Oh yeah,
he's a lot better.
What do you think about him
possibly moving to light
with two a flyweight that's
crazy,
man.
I don't know why he would want,
I don't want to fight Dj.
That makes sense.
I opened up that cash register baby.
What Demetrius is thinking
Cha Ching like fuck,
I hope he's thinking Cha Ching.
Yeah,
no shit.
I hope he realizes that that
is a legitimate super fight.
If they can prove all
that shit in advance.
Look,
mighty mouse.
I mean he's technically
for sure the and his,
his,
his ability.
He's the best.
He's the best I've ever seen.
But TJ is the scariest guy
that he's ever had a fight.
Man.
Tj goes down to one 25 if he
could do it and be healthy.
He's a scariest guy.
Mighty mouse is ever fought cause he's
a legit knockout artist at 35 he's super
fast.
He's sneaky,
he's technical.
He can wrestle.
He's a real good wrestler.
He's got a hundred percent legit knockout
power at 35 what is it going to have
at 25 you know,
I mean,
TJ might be a monster at
25 he can really make it.
That is a crazy,
crazy fight.
I love that fight.
Nobody walks around that because
I'm the right cut the 25 one time.
I did not feel like I had power.
I thought one time at 25 and I felt worse.
I don't know.
He insists that he's done it.
He insists he can make it.
He's good to set.
I know.
I can make it.
He looks smaller than
he's looked in the past.
You know,
he might've been aiming towards it,
you know,
working towards it.
But uh,
I'm super excited about his rematch.
The Cody Garbrandt.
Whew.
That's a very intense,
that's an intense fight.
That first one.
But I mean,
don't forget,
Cody cracked him and dropped
him before Tj put them away.
I mean,
that was spicy.
It was awesome.
How some real intensity wasn't it?
Fuck yeah man.
Those were close
training partners and they probably
always knew that this was one day going to
go down.
Dale was,
Cody released that video
of him knocking out Tj.
Yeah,
but the thing is he didn't knock him out,
dropped him.
A teacher was yelling at
him right after traveler.
C'Mon,
C'mon motherfucker.
So it wasn't really a knockout,
right.
It was basically the same thing
that happened in their fight.
And TJ wound up when I knock out
really was it was a flash knockdown.
They're both animals though.
I took good right there,
dude.
That's,
and you know Cody's going to
be helped bent on revenge.
Oh yeah.
That's going to be a good build up.
Fuck yeah man.
See if Cody comes back
or the same or you know,
who knows?
Who knows?
Yeah,
it's August,
August 4th all right dude,
it's already five 30
let's wrap this pitch up.
It's a long time,
long time for this podcast,
but thank you guys.
This is really fun man.
I enjoyed it.
I enjoyed it a lot,
man.
Yeah,
thank you.
This is always,
I've been watching you for a long time.
This is awesome.
Thanks man.
Like I said,
we look up to you a lot,
dude,
and we're thankful for everything.
Well,
I appreciate that,
but that makes me uncomfortable.
So don't say it anymore.
Look,
I'm just a lucky person that has a
weird job that allows me to talk to cool
people,
allows us to learn sweet shit
from pizza when we enjoy.
And we learned to sweet
shit from you guys too.
And uh,
best of luck in your continued path.
I liked what you guys are doing.
I like the way you're thinking
and I like watching your fight,
man.
You like it a lot.
All right.
That's all right,
man.
Minus two.
That's it.
Ladies and gentlemen,
sugar shot.
Give out your social media at Tim Welch.
Empty at sugar.
Sean MMA.
I just signed with
optic gaming to Oh shit.
Sugar Shawl.